can you hear us
are we alive we will know when we can be
heard
and not a moment too soon sooner
i i if you're here the camera
oh oh we're so black right now hey
it worked this time welcome people we're
live
we are live comment let us know that
we're live
are we live mirrory ethan holgate kevin
stuff
bj vlogs samuel oh my god carlos mendoza
yes we re
uh thanks all that matters i'm looking
through the discord right now
as long as we're live i don't know
exactly what we talk about today
yeah we had some internet connections as
long as we're live okay
we can't forget the super chats of the
jean jeter thank you for such a major
contribution dude
and who was the other one who jeanne
jeter and the gorillapod
okay we can't forget it thank god we're
so we're live
we're live we are live unlike the career
of christie elio we're live
[Applause]
we can still do that eminem impression
right uh sure does he
did he coin the eminem version
i mean i'm sure he's not the first
person to do one and i'm sure he's not
the first person to do one with like
that kind of
kind of you know cadence how are you
guys doing today
is is everyone doing good is that that's
right [ __ ] we're live
show show carter's comment remix threes
oh carter where we got carter
right there you see oh we're live
[ __ ]
okay part of lovejoy says this is what
we do in the first couple minutes your
first
live stream with us all we do in the
first couple of minutes is just talk
about how we're live and how that's an
accomplishment in and of itself
jazzier plays priya man we also call out
people's names just to say hey
connor mckay connor pike all right
so today okay now that we're live
today's live stream
will be about over and underrated actors
now i'm not gonna oh nissa she's at work
welcome still just the same so
originally
damn it's so it this is so yellow isn't
it
yellow uh originally
um i i thought i could come up with
overrated actors and apparently i
haven't been able to come up
with any overrated actors you guys are
getting a super behind the scenes
oh look at that that's why it's so
yellow so um
yeah the i haven't been able to cope
with any overrated actors
but i got a whole list of a bunch of
underrated actors that i want to talk
about with you guys
so here's what i'm hoping for that
happens in today's stream we can go back
and forth
between who you guys think are overrated
and we'll have a whole bunch of fun with
that one as we list off a whole bunch of
actors and actresses
that we find to personally be very
underrated
it's going to be a good time with john
campia taking a break
will be your supplement you could be the
robber meyer burnett
that's right right now i'll be the john
campbell that's who i'm gonna be
clearly this is a dig episode everyone
um but real quick so that way we can
properly keep things in function order
jean jeter i see that you super chatted
us in the previous stream that we tried
getting going
a hundred bucks holy crap dude that was
very unexpected thank you so much
really thank you dude i hope you're
being safe in new york right now
and then uh agoraphobic fanboy screen uh
super chattered us as well saying uh oh
over ryan gosling you think ryan
gosling's overrated
wow increase your super chat no
underrated bryce dallas howard she can
redirect to
you know i do think bryce dallas
howard's a rather underrated performer i
gotta give it i gotta give it to you on
that i'll give it to her
thank you agoraphobic fanboy and jean
jeter and then pcp
pop culture podcast was just on his
podcast you guys should go follow him on
instagram yeah thanks for the sticker
bud
all right so john let's bring back the
title overlay shall we we
shall alright let's do a speed round in
the comments here
ron perlman's underrated okay oh you
know i got i have an idea john i have an
idea to show everyone's comments
so you're doing this right yes
no wrong well i mean yes in some in so
many words
and then we'll bring the chat over here
oh that doesn't look good at all never
mind
this is a i'll build another window next
stream for the chat
john just i rely on him for so much i
mean there's a thing i think there's a
feature you can get where the chat just
floats off one side of the screen
transparently so we could do that too
all right let's go through the comments
here really fast and we'll look at you
guys appreciate all the super chats and
if you guys do want to contribute in any
way we also have stream labs
which uh we we do prefer to be honest
uh has one directly for you you said you
think peter sarsgaard is overrated
uh peter sarsgaard i think is that's the
only actor i can confidently
say is overrated well the thing is he's
not even rated
he's not even rating everybody's
favorite actor it seems like whoever
discovers peter sarsgaard
who played hector hammond in the green
lantern it seems like whoever discovers
him
they go wow he's a really great actor
and i don't like him
and if i met him in person i would lie
to his face and tell him he's a very
talented guy because why would i want
that level
confrontation with an actor you're
talented it's nice to meet you
you could just not talk about his acting
hi erica tuesday
oh hey dear very talented artist yes
and uh no eric is amazing and okay so
what are you guys saying in the chat
let's go through this really quick
bye crazy gamer sorry you couldn't be
here today ethan holgate is saying danny
mcbride is a bit overrated would you
agree with this assessment
i could see that a bit just because um
you know for
the peak of his popularity i feel like
he does
have a certain mode so while i
definitely enjoy danny mcbride and i
feel like
the argument it could be very uh heavily
argued if he's
overrated or not i think he could be a
little a little a little
bit overwhelmed i could see how people
could find him annoying too yeah
yeah just because like there was a time
where i was used to him showing up and
being him and sometimes that works more
than others although i do have to give
him credit he does
branch out into characters a bit more
than some of the other guys in his
position
so i'm seeing a lot of people in the
chat who have mentioned tom holland
and tom hiddleston as being overrated i
have a feeling there's going to be some
mcu names dropped oh definitely
for sure how about this do you guys
think robert downey jr is overrated
let's get some controversy open here
i see some controversy sunshine hour and
dark sidemaster both think vin diesel is
overrated and that's why you're not in
the fast
family yeah i i don't quite
grab you know what i might meet you
there i like vin diesel he's
fun but i can't quite grasp why he is
the sensation that he
is like some people i bet there's gonna
be some people saying the rock in here a
lot of people are gonna be saying dwayne
johnson
for overrated or underrated overall
the [ __ ] are you tired i'm overrated an
underrated actor totally
there's gonna be people who are gonna be
saying dwayne johnson's overrated right
i think there's a much stronger argument
to be made for
but you see the thing is i think this
vin diesel is a weird case because i
think the the position
of stardom of why the movies that vin
diesel has done that have made him a
superstar
i can't quite grasp why he's so famous
for that on the other end of the
spectrum
he's actually a really underrated
dramatic
actor so for the movies that have made
him the sensation that he is
i don't quite get it i don't find those
performances all that
crazy or what i'm like why is why is he
this famous
but he's also an incredible dramatic
actor
and a lot of people don't know that so
in some ways he's a little bit both
overrated and underrated his chops are
underrated
and he gets to strut them less of the
time than i would hope
for because yeah even in stuff like be
cool like he's one of the highlights of
that movie
oh that's a comedic role john i totally
agree with you thank you you're talking
about dwayne johnson
oh who do we i was talking about vin
diesel oh whoops
yeah i mean he does have times where
yeah he can channel that and he gets
called upon and i feel like the roles
that he loves to do
as much as he brings that like i'm
freaking serious about this are not
those kinds of dramatic
rules like his like that uh witch hunter
movie was like based on his dnd
character and that was a passion project
so that's what i was so scared i'm
seeing people in the chat
talking about tom cruise being oh okay
this is what's gonna be fun
i can feel this live stream already why
it's going to be fun because i'm going
to name off a whole i got a whole list
here of
underrated actors you can't see it on
screen but i got a holiday
card a little tease i got a whole list
of underrated actors and actresses
and you guys are going to be dropping
all these overrated actors and actresses
and that's what's gonna be fun about
this and then we could go back and forth
on that because i wouldn't have thought
of the whole vin diesel thing if it
wasn't
for you guys in this live stream right
now dude some people calling out a few
people calling on angela bassett as
being
underrated which i would go for oh my
god yeah he's got
huge talent speaking of they're gonna
say huge tits and i was gonna be like i
don't remember
let me go back you said a huge
tit and then my that wasn't my fault all
right that was
that was kind of my fault it is it was a
subconscious thought that i expressed to
you guys i'm sorry
it's okay it's okay but she is very
underrated i mean
we just brought peter sarsgaard as
hector hammond in green lantern angela
bassett was amanda waller
in greenland oh wow okay not bad very
underrated
you know who is the better that's
underrated too she's a character all the
amanda wallers
are underrated let's get a team-up movie
of all the amanda waller actors
what the hell amanda while they're into
the waller
why haven't we gotten those ah think of
it every different university is
assembling a different team it would be
great
uh okay i'm seeing a lot of love for
shia labeouf being
underrated you know what's funny shia
labeouf
went from overrated to
weird [ __ ] personal life to now being
he's an underrated actor he went from
overrated
way over way underrated it's kind of
funny with that guy's career
like hugely overrated public persona and
yeah
yeah and then in recent years everyone's
like he's making these really good
movies where he's like acting and
digging deep within yourself and it's
very funny i like his
uh real life character i mean yeah a lot
of people think dwayne johnson's
overrated that's coming yeah
you see i i can't i ca i can't fault you
i mean i love dwayne johnson i do
i love him but i can't i don't really
know how to defend
why he's like i think he's overrated
because he's at a point right now where
he doesn't have to grow or push himself
of what kinds of roles he takes i feel
like he already proved himself i feel
like there was a time where he could be
like
yeah but his comedy skills are very
underrated but he's already proven he's
amazing at comedy
yeah all right before we get to like i
appreciate all the super chats that have
come in so far
i don't um and then like i said also
please hit that like button if this is
your first time here
um okay so i want to name off uh a
couple
of of my
underrated performers okay okay on one
list i have white people on the other i
have people of color
got to keep those lists
you got to make sure john okay first one
christie elia very underrated actor
the guy who voiced cleveland very
underrated actor
jimmy marbles jenna marbles
[Laughter]
i'm in a mood today okay my first one my
first real one
i'm gonna go with evan peters i think
evan peters is a very underrated actor
and i feel like most of you guys will
know him as quicksilver right then i
don't fault you on that
um and then uh the rest of you guys will
know american horror story
now his perform i've said this for many
years now his work on american horror
story reminds me of a young johnny depp
who some people probably think is
overrated and is now underrated because
he's bouncing back
but um but uh evan peters his work on
american horror story
has demonstrated such a wide range of
different performances
on that show alone because every episode
is a comp
is a restart essentially uh and his work
on there
i really hope one day he could be a like
a big movie star because he's he
deserves it he's a very talented actor
who doesn't get to stretch that acting
range as much on the big screen
so thank god he's really tight with that
ryan murphy fella because he gets a lot
of work that he gets to do there where
you're like man this guy's this guy's
amazing he's incredible on that show
he's incredible
john do you have an underrated performer
you'd like to share or an overrated
performer
i've got an underrated performer uh her
name is sarah snook
and uh ooh went with the woman and i
went with the white man how does that
make me
look she's a white woman so fair enough
oh
so i'm not i'm not that much woker than
you damn it
um but yeah should we restart the
livestream yes i think we should restart
cut it all down um people still can't
pick up on my sarcasm
i have discovered as of late you know
hey it's going to be with you throughout
your life but that's going to lead to a
lot of
interesting scenarios it wouldn't have
otherwise true
um yeah sarah snook i think is a
terrific actress i think she's
australian
and i first saw her in a spirit brothers
movie called predestination
where she has so much she's got to do
she stars opposite ethan hawk and that
was yeah my first introduction to her
she's in a not
as great movie follow-up from those
directors which was winchester but now i
think she's on um
uh that hbo succession i think she's on
now so she's getting work for sure but
um every time i've seen her on screen
she
just brings this really lived in
uh beautiful quality and and yeah like a
film like predestination which is this
i think it's based on like a robert
heinlein short or something it's a very
out there and very
obtuse in some ways sci-fi movie and and
yeah she carries it with such poise and
such heart and i i
can't wait to see what else she does
very good john
thank you very good call thanks dog all
right we're gonna look at the chat some
more erica agrees i think jericho
wants uh evan peters to voice one of the
people in her show dude evan peters
would be cool
uh sunshine in the chat is saying jamie
curtis is perfectly rated
who do you think is perfectly rated guys
leave your thoughts down below
robert uh becerra was that uh uh uh
calling out uh [ __ ] uh uh walton goggins
which uh i love walking
very underrated great character actor
and great actor in general
killian murphy i agree i agree with that
assessment for sure
a thousand killian murphy wildly
underrated would have been a much better
batman than christian bale
hot takes controversial live stream oh
and leo dicaprio would have been a
better patrick bateman
you know what i want you know what i
want there to be a cartoon that explores
the alternate universe where all those
alternate casting choices happen
all right guys well we should probably
catch up on some of these super chats
you guys have been so generous
i love these topics because you guys
constantly keep contributing so much
more so i try to stay focused when i'm
talking
but then i started reading what you guys
will assume like i got to make sure to
talk about him before more comments come
in
all right pj pandemic jones in the in
the pandemic
in the super chat what up guys thank you
this
actually came up last uh uh live stream
one of my favorite
actors one of my favorite actors who i
think is underrated is lakeith
stanfield love all his movies john who's
number two on my list this is
oh my gran real order but who's number
two on my list i can verify
this la keith stanfield you guys can see
no tricks bright light shots no camera
edits
no lighting functional
yeah i agree pj la keith sandfield is a
highly
highly underrated actor man if you guys
haven't seen sorry to bother you that's
just an underrated movie in general
sorry to bother you atlanta even he was
even great in the photograph
you know what else he's great in what
get out
was that a sneeze yeah get out oh get
out that's right
he's the one who says he's the one who
says the title of the movie
i apologize i heard ah and then daniel
is like you get out
you get all right that's how i would
have written that scene
you get out freaking out go [ __ ]
yourself
anissa hey brandon v oh brandon much
love
buddy i hope you're doing well uh anissa
wish i could be here to watch
it all love y'all well hey it's okay
okay you're doing the important lord's
work
and niece is in texas right now and she
works at an er
i'll tell you exactly what er so that
way you guys in texas can go visit her
she works on a knee our covet cases are
going through the roof over there so her
work
is necessary so it needs to keep doing
the good deed
and thanks for this friend shirt by the
way that she gave me and this got
salt supernatural shirt thank you anisa
i really appreciate
you stay sexy pop culture podcast next
overrated actor or do you want to take
this because you were just on the pop
culture podcast pop culture podcast was
just on it guys go follow him on
instagram link in the bio
for it um he says thank you pop culture
podcast by the way
overrated actor oh
oh this is getting fun
jeff goldblum oh
i could i don't i could i could get
where you're coming from an
underrated actor sam rockwell
the man who won an oscar just last year
sam rockwell has finally climbed to
being properly raided
um he's rated now in my opinion uh
well i think jeff goldblum i think the
personality of jeff
goldblum yeah has overshadowed his
talents
you know what i mean because there was a
time where jeff goldblum was
like a real i mean he's still he's great
still i still think jeff
goldblum's great whatever he shows up in
he steals the show
plain and simple there's no other way
around it for me especially his own show
yeah especially the world according to
yep something like that so um that jeff
goldblum
constantly steals the show right and uh
the thing though is he used to
demonstrate a wide range of talent and
now he just shows up and be
a great version of jeff goldblum every
time now but he used to really
demonstrate a range you know and really
morph into these characters and
it's only once in a while that you
really get to see that and maybe that's
on the studios that hire him in the
movies like
big bigger movies cast him now to be
jeff goldblum
essentially yeah um he's chris watkin
now he's come in him do your thing
but he could get a chance to demonstrate
himself and like small
like a wes anderson movie he really gets
a chance to demonstrate so i don't blame
you for that
jeff jeff goldblum the actor i would say
is underrated currently but jeff
goldblum the personality is highly
overrated at the moment as much as i
like him
yeah still very talented guy though
undoubtedly uh thank you guys
and uh yeah if you guys are just showing
up or been liking it here hit the like
button we've got a couple uh decent call
outs here in the chat as
well and one of them is whoa john we
gotta stay focused
if we have the super chats on screen
we remove the super chats and then we
bring back the title overlay so everyone
knows what we're talking about for those
who are hopping in
we gotta tend to a lot of different
eyeballs right now okay
we it's a lot to do and you your 80d
mind
can really screw this up john this is
called
belittling the white man
[Laughter]
that's right thank you may i have
another
times are changed trying to make up for
for for
just existing right now
underrated we got matthew lillard in
here but somebody said and you were
somebody who who echoed this sentiment
to me long before
anybody uh that toby maguire should have
won an oscar for
brothers says benjamin callinicos
i agree man uh toby maguire was amazing
in the movie brothers
uh and i feel like not enough people
really gave him the proper recognition
he deserved in that
mm-hmm um yeah i agree with that
who else do we got in here says that uh
nicholas cage is not raided he is his
own entity which is
true oh my god yeah he doesn't belong in
this discussion
rick dalton is an underrated actor
daniel craig overrated ooh uh-oh i'm
seeing
love for ben affleck being underrated
and you know it's funny i
saw a list on reddit that was like the
most
reddit is the most credible source in
the world is it not
yes and i saw a list that was saying
that ben affleck is up there
actually the name johnny depp is number
one most overrated actor
but i would like to take time out really
quick
to read another underrated performer
here we go her name is rosario dawson
one of the coolest most badass women
working in the business today and yes
she's gonna be ahsoka tano so more
people might
depending on the length of her role in
the mandalorian season two
people might get to really be more
familiar with her
but she is an incredible incredible
actress she's like the embodiment of
like
sweet sexy has a lot of nuance
depth really badass but tender like
she's got all the qualities
wrapped them into one blanket just about
it she's an incredible actress
i love her man and i would also say
lupita nyong'o as well
i'm just going in the liz with my order
here lupita nyong'o
doesn't like no especially after us bro
the oscar snub of us is enough to prove
how
[ __ ] underrated she becomes the most
popular actress in hollywood tomorrow
she's still got
five years worth of underrated cred from
that snub yes
you know uh that's a great great call
dylan o'brien i see
i need a carter lovejoy's comment i need
that to be shown
he says any actor that becomes a
youtuber
is [ __ ] overrated oh you should have
seen
there's a whole recurring uh john
krasinski beef on patrick h willems
lately
what why because uh some good news
has terrible sound quality and uh and
you know he was
apparently just kind of irked that uh
you know john krasinski dipped into
youtube for a hot minute to sell a tv
show
and then dipped out whatever man it's
free
it was a funny taking views away funny
bit oh okay it's a funny bit the way you
set it up made it
he was like [ __ ] you know shooting
like mad at him there's a recurring bit
john c reilly underrated uh in any pt
anderson film that's a cool one
oh man i just lost it because too many
comments are coming in honor the armist
someone said it in the chat yeah honor
they arm
why did not enough people talk about her
when knives out all the love went to
daniel craig's performance which was
great
but anna de armas that was her movie
dude she deserved a lot more credit
she's being uh you know undercut by
knock knock still
yeah that's true damn it i'm a good guy
um we are not underrated reactors we are
totally overrated i saw a cough
jack black cough are we which direction
is that going in erica because i cannot
uh take jack black blasphemy right now
all right so
uh but hold on before we go back chill
level tv said that we are the underrated
actors
i appreciate that thank you very much tv
that's very kind
oh peter pacheco oh my god peter pacheco
is here like every stream what's wrong
john
if you want to keep it lined up oh thank
god i'm trying to keep us
really calm today okay we can't freak
out because then i get way too ahead of
myself and i say stupid things
and i've already done enough of that on
this stream in the last 20 minutes
trying to make sure i keep an even keel
today i'm a peter pacheco
uh read this in your best uh portuguese
accent greg
okay portuguese coming at you
now this might sound like a
stereotypical portuguese accent but i'm
doing my best okay
underrated anne hathaway essay
bill mostly uh gary oldman overrated vin
diesel
oh sorry i know i know it's like oh my
god you're doing a stereotypical
um accent uh
but i did my best stereotypically
authentic i'm so sorry stereotypically
but i feel like for a stereotypical
portuguese accent
i hit the nail on the head totally
definitely there's no denying that
uh what did you say uh uh underrated
anne hathaway
wow you know there was a time where
people would really jump on the anne
hathaway hate train
and hateaway is what i used to call it
good
bill mosley oh dude that guy can be more
than loud bill mosley deserves more love
um wait are you saying wait is it in
your comment are you saying
gary oldman is overrated cannot agree
with you dude
i'm sorry peter pacheco appreciate the
super chat i think
i can't agree with it i think he's
saying gary is underrated okay because
it goes into over here
oh okay i thought he was saying like
gary i'm gonna write we're safe
there's another vin diesel comment here
about how he's over right
sorry like getting on my old man gary
just was really upset i didn't realize
gary old
i mean uh that vin diesel had such a an
over i
yeah i just wasn't aware thought he was
not a highly rated actor
oh man but at least thank you peter
pacheco and obviously you're a bill
mosley fan with your
uh um face there rest in peace
all right will heron i don't think this
is the first time i think i've seen your
name before
hello will herron will will winona ryder
underrated so is mel gibson both of them
and
i hear they're best friends now hey you
guys heard the news what
i'm i'm breaking news winona ryder and
mel gibson
are engaged holding here they're getting
married
how awesome was that how terrible would
that be what a weird universe we would
live in no they are not getting along
um will herndon thank you buddy thank
you so much underrated
scarlett johansson while she's
really missing mcu films her roles in
just take up
just take just please oh i just want to
sit wait a minute wait a minute so i
started talking and then you just
interrupt me you think you just over
power interrupted you like my life when
have i ever interrupted
i'm trying to do a bit about you being
white i am white this is
me exerting my privilege over you i want
to finish this damn sentence
um sorry john read the comment please
jablinski games all right underrated
scarlett johansson while she's famous in
mcu
films her roles in under the skin lost
in translation
jojo rabbit her depressed stage
are some of the best showcases of female
acting
ever i agree will um
i don't have some great indie roles yeah
she's an amazing actress
and she's kind of in not necessarily
the same thing but kind of that vin
diesel thing i was talking about where
she's like super famous and i think if
people only see like her really most
popular movies
people might think she's overrated but
when you look at them the smaller films
like the ones you listed you'd see that
scarlett johansson has a wide range of
talent
[ __ ] marriage stories he didn't even
say marriage story here
marriage story absolutely laura dern
another underrated actress right there
my god i mean i know whoa were you
reading out of the chat just there or
did you come up with that off
off the top oh dude that's what i only
oh every video all i do is read a
comment and then i make it sound like
it's my own opinion and everyone's like
i agree with you greg that's how you do
it
totally definitely definitely 100 100
john please oh no i didn't do anything
um aneesa's back
just rolling in all the co-vid at work
so if anybody wants to come down with
something just go out
go out to tejas you know that she's
doing hard work when she's watching a
live stream
oh yeah at the er that's what i want for
my
er receptionist or whatever she does
with the administrator
or something i'm freaking no i'm kidding
i'm kidding please keep watching the
live stream
ignore them i want you here at nissa you
know how much we love you thank you
anisa
and then uh john mirrory mirrory
underrated kara hayward and thomas and
mackenzie
who are they okay so thomas and
mackenzie i remember
is uh uh the girl in the attic and jojo
okay living in the wall uh oh yeah yeah
definitely a thousand percent agree with
you there
cara hayward i don't have a line on at
the moment but uh very good young
actresses
overrated oh laura just adjusted the one
i said is underwater
and emma watson she was good in harry
potter's
whoa i don't think emma watson is
overrated just yet
well mary thank you for your
contribution at the same time though
i have to strongly disagree with you
here
that thomason mckenzie kid is awful
see that's what we call subverting
expectations and
john let me tell you okay oh what what i
was doing was i was making it sound like
i was about to talk about
uh you know laura dern yeah and defend
her there in your comments yeah what
happened
really what i did was i threw a left i
went left field
it was that was the left turn so you
went left i took a left turn when i
expected you to keep going straight
exactly
that's how we did it whoa who is kara
hayward so
not oh she's the girl from the moonrise
kingdom yeah
she's the uh the the love interesting oh
yeah yeah the main female young lead in
moonrise kingdom
oh she's great uh yeah all right cool
well thank you well thank you marie love
your name by the way is that a top hat
and then uh we'll do one more and then
we'll uh get back to some of the
comments here
from niraj what's up dog raj
overrated sean penn and julia roberts
oh i love how confident say overrated
champ and comma to julia julia
one of each right there i don't know i
mean why would sean penn be over oh well
sometimes he tries it seems like he's
trying a little too hard but he's
knocked out he's
he's got like two oscars under his belt
doesn't he is he that underrated
he can he can come off as pretentious i
guess i
i guess he's a sean penn he's overrated
to me in the sense that i think he's a
great actor but he is one of those guys
where i'm like
i don't think i want to hang out with
you and you do
come off kind of like condescending in a
way that doesn't back up some of the
things i've heard about you
that's fair um i would say julia roberts
yeah i can't i see the overweight is a
much harder category for me
because a lot of times what people do is
they go through like their most popular
movies
and she has a string of movies that are
just so [ __ ] popular for such a long
time
um i don't know if i've ever seen a
julia roberts performance that i've been
in love with
aaron brockovich okay
she's a british she's really great in
erin brockovich i'll give you that yeah
and everything else she's very likable
you know ocean's twelve
what other powerful performance i'm sure
she's got to have at least one other one
right
gotta have it well yeah i'm trying to
think now too because i feel like i've
seen it i mean like pretty woman's great
she comes from the time of like when
hollywood made stars yeah you know 1930s
the golden age of hollywood making
pictures at mgm
rko ako radio pictures
charlie cox says jack sparrow underrated
uh
jackson okay let's see underrated keanu
reeves i think
nowadays is he's probably rated if not i
i would hate him to be overrated but if
it's going in any direction right no
all right okay i saw a couple of people
mentioned his name timothy shalamy
what do you think uh uh
i guess at the moment i would go a
little bit overrated just because uh
he's
recent on to the scene he's the newest
it thing
people be losing their minds to cast him
all over the place and uh you know
i mean his star is certainly high but
it's been a minute since i've heard like
oh man
this timothy challenge performances like
you have to check out
um so i don't know i think he's terrific
in what i've seen
and uh but i don't know i he's rated too
overrated in my mind
overrated in a non-negative kind of way
i'm just like i don't know i
i guess i would like to see this kid
demonstrate some longevity he's got my
hair but
better so he's [ __ ] whoa whoa
don't sell yourself he's got my kind of
hair
but it just looks so much better so much
better so do you know who he's dating
who is what
how did he get i i'm sorry all right i
just don't get how he got eyes again
well they're both he's a good looking
dude all right but you don't understand
because
beside in fact i saw somebody say uh
that adam driver was underrated and i
thought to myself besides
adam driver timothy shalom is like the
most popular actor right now at least in
terms of like
young heart throbbers i mean that's fair
but adam driver is amazing he's not
underrated
that driver blows me okay let's look at
the recent star wars trilogy with adam
driver
he's one of the better parts because
he's the only part where everyone's like
but you know who's [ __ ]
great in the hoses and despite the
writing people can even say like while
they yeah
what kylo ren does they like what adam
driver does yeah
he's awesome in that tim roth underrated
that's a cool one
tim roth i feel like has a lot more
broader career than tarantino
would have you believe i'm seeing people
in the chat mentioning
gal gadot guys
as overrated imagine
there's no heaven
you know that was one of the greatest
trolling performances
john just spilled a whole bunch of lick
this is what happens when you get jumpy
this is why i've been trying to keep a
calm attitude jesus why we're trying to
keep this is why i'm trying to keep
combined by like being manic
i haven't been manic you just spilled a
bunch of
of orange juice not mixed of orange
shrooms that would be a gram
surprise on a live stream oh man people
do like drunk live streams we should do
a shrooms live stream i've never had
shrooms that's
can you believe that should me yeah
we'll just do a live stream where we
watch
fractals expand and then contemplate our
insignificance in the universe before
having ego death who wants
okay when we get a p.o box who wants to
send greg some shrooms
you know that's not a bad way to to get
a hook up who wants to mail us some
mushrooms all right let's see here oh
giovanni rabizi
as underrated he is underrated
absolutely i love that choice
colin farrell i see underrated actor
maybe a little overrated personality but
uh but as an actor i think he's got
chops
okay i've been seeing too many people
bring this up jenna marbles will return
she ain't going away
all right that's why i've never i don't
find it to be like she's
if anything she's taking an extended
break but she'll be back
i know her personally maybe all of us
youtubers we talked today special
club yeah and we all know each other so
well
there are updates weekly for us bill
hater he's on the rise to being like
the guy that thing chapter
yeah he's on the rise and then soon we
will be saying
bill hader is overrated right now he is
underrated
it's rare where you get someone who's
perfectly rated you know
like daniel day lewis is one of those
actors i think
somebody i think said this too who will
be like he's overrated and then it's
so easy to defend why he is
not overrated yeah i can get there too
like a guy's a little overrated then you
start
thinking about it like actually he's
pretty much the greatest [ __ ] actor
have you ever lived you know yeah and
it's like even if you don't necessarily
emotionally attach to his roles like
there's just no denying his level of
skill it's so true
matter of fact he can get away with
blackface yeah
he's the only one he just hangs out that
way at home yeah
he's like this is probably for a new
character and he's going to win an oscar
he's going to win an oscar for shooting
the most offensive film of all time but
taking it and then as he's winning the
oscar other people will get cancelled
for doing blackface everyone involved
with the film except
nuts everyone will be like this [ __ ]
this movie this movie is bad for society
crazy yet we still can't deny how great
daniel day lewis was
in it give him the oscar cancel everyone
involved
oh i see lucas hedges in here oh [ __ ] we
got some streamlabs
oh my god you guys have gone to some of
you guys have gone to our stream labs
john
yeah if you would like it uh it helps us
out i mean super chat's very much
appreciated but also the stream labs
they don't take as much in
fees so if you just you know care about
that uh
you know the biggest bang for everyone
they care way more about that than we
care about that let's make it clear
as if hey when i support people i like
oh eric horseman thank you dude my god
dude you were the most
thank you eric are you selling the drugs
and drinks that you imbibe
or or do you just have an endless
fountain of money thank you so much eric
eric says overrated kevin costner
every movie underrated
sigourney weaver have you seen gorillas
in the mist
she's more than just ripley true that
she is more than just ripley as great as
ripley is she is more than
than just ripley come to think of it i
can't think of a kevin costner
performance where i was like
i see why kevin coster's the man
i feel like i feel like the biggest
arguments for his collective
just just you know artistic talent i
feel like have have
some involvement with his director man
of steel come on
i know i know i have at least one friend
who like loves kevin costner and
even in that movie he was like can't
because [ __ ] great and i was like
he's great
he's not the greatest representation of
that character oh
but dude come on man little clark kent's
like
papa am i still your son of course
you're my son
oh my god it's so beautiful in the
trailer it hit harder in the trailer
than it did for me
well the thing about kevin costner is
that kevin costner could sometimes be a
little wooden
and uh i feel like i'll give it to him
and in man of steel he
wasn't casting
uh but sigourney weaver uh yeah
definitely an underrated actress
yes and still looks [ __ ] great i know
holy
crap yeah kevin costner though
i mean not look great she does not get
enough credit in a day and age
where when you reboot charlie's angels
and for some reason it still gets
woke comment crap when i'm like it's for
being uh
she's charlie's angels what the [ __ ]
women kicking ass in this movie are
based on the property where women kick
ass
call me by your name is amazing i do
want to clear that up um
so so uh but sigourney weaver man her
role as
ripley is just phenomenal and then she's
done so many
like even in ghostbusters i think she's
great she might not be like the funny
one in it but she's even great in that
movie
uh working girl another one that i
really liked her in
and um oh yeah yeah the uh gorilla's in
the mist as well
yeah avatar the last airbender
she is great in that show yeah god damn
it's funny you know like i i'm gonna
jump on the train for some of these of
going yeah they're overrated then i see
they get offended and i'm like oh
now i'm now and now i have to take it
back kyle mclaughlin
always underrated naomi campbell also
underrated
thanks martin give it to her she's great
and 28 days later okay
let's see who else do i got on this list
i got an interesting one
all right oh wait wait oh me me and
thank you so much and thank you eric
again me me and thank you
wow you jumped to your list before the
graphic was down
i guess myself before you did
that that means that i have no grounds
get your
hands off of her
get your damn crisping glover underrated
[ __ ] right there oh my
god i've got some friends who've made
films with him in prague i hear he's
easy to work with i
do too breezy experience is what they
say
underrated nicole barry uh black mirror
striking vipers episode oh [ __ ] yeah
yeah
she is yeah yeah yeah tony shalhoub
hell yeah thank you jamon han jaimon
hanson
is it okay somebody clear this up for me
and i'm really asking for serious is it
is it like
is do you combine the d and the j is it
like jaimon or is it digimon because
i've
heard it in both ways digimon digital
monsters
that's let's get things straight digimon
i want to be certain jeffrey wright uh i
he's he's he's getting he's getting his
profile blown up lately but yeah
jefferson
commissioner gordon for more than 10
minutes he will outperform jk simmons
michaela cole new uh i may destroy you
new hbo show i don't think i've heard of
that uh
overrated good old ansel elgort
he's been in the me he's been in the
media later emma watson that is
two two essential super chats to this
live stream
that have singled out emma watson
apparently
no love for emma watson anymore and mark
wahlberg
hot take tom cruise overrated i don't
think that's a hot take though
do you feel like people think
i feel like i'm a tom cruise defender
now
yeah i've really it goes it oscillates i
feel like you have to get tom cruise
like he gets to a point every so often
where everyone's done with it and
they're like i'm sick of this guy and
then
every movie that comes out you're like
but he's a great actor and then you know
uh once he falls from grace a little bit
you know then you get your chance again
to build him up
i mean i love i love all your picks like
jamon hansu i bring this up all the time
comic book connoisseur he is in kingsman
the king he's in the king's man now sam
he's the
he's the wizard he is korath
in guardians of the galaxy he's papa
midnight
in constantine he's done
oh he's an aquaman i don't remember who
he is in aquaman but he's an aquaman
but a lot of people don't realize that
dude's liking so much comic book
properties on top of that just an
amazing actor
amazon blood diamond [ __ ] incredible
he is yeah and i feel like he is
underrated
in in especially like non-comic like for
his acting
chops like that dude can which is i'm
really excited for a quiet place too
because i hope that that can be a
blockbuster
that gets to capitalize on his and then
everyone will talk about killian
and how he's underrated jeffrey wright
is uh i've been watching him since
angels in america played two different
characters in there and
i think he might have played three but
for sure he played every character he
played al pacino playing a character in
angels in america
um but yeah not familiar with the other
ones i mean let's face it the media is
already taking out ansel elgort and mark
wahlberg temporarily i'll be back up
there you know how it goes with those
kind of people
so well yeah uh but yeah thank you thank
you guys for the ones who contributed
here over
streaming labs that means a lot too i
know it's kind of an annoying to get out
of your way to go to streamlabs but
seriously it's always like extra extra
appreciate when you like go to
streamlabs
i know you'll agree with me m on this
one but let's get that graphic back
tim blake nelson ooh underrated actor
under rated actors dude if you watch
what's i'm catching watching
yeah you're finally watching watchmen
yeah i got my hbo go uh
hbo whatever setup i didn't want the hbo
max
i just went with the hbo go i have hbo
go through cable it's free for me
you can't you just get it with the cable
i'm getting rid of hbo go you can't
well then i'll upgrade to hbo max
upgrade i don't know i logged in and i
was able to watch my programs okay so it
worked
all right but i'll switch to max and
then we can message each other let's see
what you guys are saying in the chat
here
what do we got on the chat so whenever
this graphic is up on screen
that means we're just going to your
comments in the live stream
all right let's see here tim blake
nelson sebastian stan
kate blanchett under you know kate
blanchett i always thought she would be
a lot more famous by now
yeah she i really did think she would be
i feel like
kate blanchett like has had such a good
track record that she just
ascended to elder state's personhood
without having to get too overrated
like if she got to an overrated point i
think it was probably around the crystal
skull times
apologize if the stream's a little bit
delayed guys internet troubles
the quarantines the the covet situation
has made things
so much more intense and more people are
home now than
last week yeah it's going crazy so a lot
more people are staying home in
california
jack sparrow oh sorry what did you see
what did you see uh what were you uh
hold on a second kristen stewart
overrated
i don't know about that i think her
acting chops are underrated
i think i think kristen stewart gets a
lot of unnecessary hate for twilight
and a couple of other things she's done
but her acting talents are actually
really great and i feel like i feel like
she's actually underrated to a certain
degree
i would say that's twilight overrated
whereas her persona
yeah exactly i'm a kristen stewart
apologist
ooh albert brooks albert brooks in drive
hell yeah shaved his eyebrows mark of a
good actor
and getting fat or ridiculously skinny
yeah
mark of another great actor oh mark i
see mark ruffalo in here
i see uh uh let's see oh john bernthal
is a good one viggo mortensen mark
ruffalo oh come on
i think paul rudd is rated i think he is
he is
squarely rated right now he can traverse
between different genres but he's also
like beloved by
america oh man lana pico don't like who
do you not like lana
tell us who you don't like specifically
we need specific comments john hurt
patrick warburton underrated i like that
pic
i like that pic yeah robert pattinson
underrated
we'll just wait till the batman comes
out not since he stopped working out now
now he's overrated because he's not
working out allison is saying paul
bettany
is underrated who's rob morgan well paul
bettany is dryden boss
yeah uh sean astin so underrated
yeah you know what i i give it to you
god you know this
since this live stream started there's
someone jumping in to say killian murphy
every single time killian murphy rob
morgan is a good actor i just looked him
up he's in just mercy but he's also in
uh the the
daredevil verse ah yeah yeah he's great
misha collins def college let's get this
out of the way
the cast of supernatural underrated all
right
everyone in supernatural yes especially
bobby
um tom holland over i've seen a few
people mention tom holland in this
stream
both under and over there's a lot of
argument about tom
about being over and underrated yeah
really well not people are going back
and forth but i've seen under and over
multiple times lb lee pace good call
fair enough all right i want to name off
one uh two more really quick
all right cameron monahan one of the
most
underrated actors working today
i um i finally finished gotham last week
in that show he's played five different
versions
of like the these twins right he plays
jerome when jerome's normal to jerome
joker to jeremiah to jeremiah joker and
then
um a much older version of the joker
the guy is exceptional i'm halfway
through or somewhere like
the third of the way through jedi fallen
order right now
and even in that game i'm like this
guy's [ __ ] great
he's great he's a [ __ ] great actor
cameron monahan
deserves a lot of my picks actually come
from television
um rhea seahorn from better call saul
if you guys are not watching better call
salt oh my god you're missing out
and ria seahorn deserves a [ __ ] emmy
nomination
at the minimum like she really
really does ria seahorn better call saul
mind blown seriously you know who i also
think is
underrated in the cast of better call
saul is um
all of them just say all of them
everyone on
a weak link and better call us all but
uh patrick fabian i think i've seen him
in some other stuff and he's
pretty great too michael mando as
nacho who you guys might better know him
as scorpion
and that one little bit in spider-man
homecoming
is so [ __ ] good everyone i'm better
call
saul are all underrated actors even
right down to bob odenkirk god damn it
i don't remember who called him out but
somebody uh pointed out jonah hill
especially for being able to stand toe
to toe against leo for an entire movie
in wolf
fair enough underrated it looks like
we've really fallen behind on some
stupid let's
get back to the super yes i'll agree
with you chadwick boseman
let's get this guy out of the way he's
done more than black panther all right
he's done much more than blackmailer uh
all right
oh goodness gracious me we have fallen
behind
we got michael swift michael swift
thank you michael smith for contributing
here to our live stream hey
oh oh you just go john's this is a great
freaking call
john's day richard brady you just made
john's dick
i don't know if he's underrated or
overrated but i think he's a good actor
i think
i mean not hardly anybody knows the
man's name but you have
seen his roles he was joe chill and
batman begins he's the night king
he is terrifying in rob zombies 31 as
doom head
he's the he's the night king he's the
night king
in game game of thrones yeah among other
things among other things yeah
he's the knight richard brake has hella
roles that you wouldn't realize yeah
yeah yeah
yeah totally richard brake usually plays
like creepy ass [ __ ] or right
he does he's like
like where ben mendelsohn was at some
point in his career before people
more people started like ben
mendelsohn's
when he's not doing like comic book
villains but then he's like the creepier
version of
ben mendel's yeah that's like the
position he holds in the movie sphere
currently seriously look at richard
brake you wouldn't regret it he always
always steals the show oh yeah he's a
mandy as the guy with the tiger right
yeah he's yesterday
thank you for mentioning michael swift
thank you so much ooh
we got dominic zafferes oh what is sarah
sexy name
underrated he's on my list thank you hey
mads mickelson willem dafoe and gary
oldman
yeah gary oldman's more known now but i
still feel like he doesn't get the
gary ellen's a weird level because gary
oldman is
way more known now i think he's rated i
don't know about that i
i feel like he should be in the category
where people are saying he's overrated
and you have to defend why he's not
overrated
like that that's where i think gary
oldman should be like he should be in
that daniel day-lewis position
um because he is [ __ ] insanely great
and i feel like more people know him now
than ever but i don't feel like he says
i feel like he's you know what it is
he's under-appreciated there you go hey
that's a great that's a great
distinction i know john i'm great with
the words that's what people need me for
is the words
uh you're the one willing to foe another
and
if i put him in the same category like
most people know willem the foe i think
but i think he's an underappreciated
actor um
and mads mikkelsen i have
i know michael b's in this live stream
um i have
one episode left of hannibal to go and
yeah um
i think he is personally i prefer him
over anthony hopkins uh hannibal and
mads mikkelsen
he has this magnetic quality not just in
hannibal
generally speaking there's this strange
magnetism that mads mickelson has he
doesn't have to do
much even he could just be looking at
someone or something
and you're drawn to the guy uh mads
mickelson is a very
underrated actor he's 100 on my list so
yeah thank you for mentioning him
all right hi lana follow her
john take it away read lana's comment
please kristen
stewart when the indie root after
twilight which i felt gave her an
overrated reputation for her acting oh
damn
and i hear i was just defending her
underrated i would say sebastian stan
especially in i tonya well that's the
thing is i think
i think twilight definitely blew like
everyone's reputation out of proportion
taylor
lautner robert pattinson everybody
involved at least in the main cast
um but i think that both she and rpatz
she doesn't get the respect
but uh i still think that her chops are
underrated even if her
persona and the effects it has may be a
bit overrated
but uh friggin um sebastian stan
what would you say what would you say
for sebastian stan being underrated yeah
i i mean yeah i think of sebastian
stan's like an under
i mean like yeah and a lot of people
still don't know his name actually
and i think he deserves a lot more
praise for his work
because he's done a lot of films he's
not just winter soldier you know
but i feel like more people will and and
i even feel like as
bucky barnes a lot of people don't
appreciate his work as much but i think
when the show comes out there's going to
be a lot more appreciation for his work
as bucky barnes because right now
right now with bucky it seems like a lot
of the female fan base gravitates
he's a [ __ ] sexy dark guy or the
beard
but but i think in terms of performances
he's going to be getting i think
his work as winter soldier will be a lot
more appreciated
you know what i mean you know what i
mean i know exactly what you mean
dan stevens is working the guest i would
say is underrated okay
and in eurovision thank you lana pico
all right you're doing great work lana
thank you
carter lovejoy this is a great one voice
actors in general are
super underrated what are you talking
about
will ferrell and megamind yeah yeah yeah
gal gadot
in uh wreck-it ralph two ralph two um
who else we got uh martin scorsese and
sinbad de niro in shark tale will smith
and sharks
all those dreamworks animation movies
give a lot of work
everyone every voiceover
everyone is not jack black and jackie
chan in in
in in kung fu panda no i i it's kind of
it is a shame i agree with you
love joy i appreciate you saying that it
is a goddamn shame that not enough voice
actors get enough
oh yeah praise for their their names
just don't get known
and i i'm at fault for that too because
i can't name you
majority of the people i can't name you
anyone else in pocahontas besides mel
gibson
and that's all me like i've never taken
the time and nor are they pushed to the
forefront
and so yeah i i do think um it is a
shame that a lot
a lot more people aren't uh appreciating
voice-over actors
yeah especially because they're like so
many of these people you
hear awesome
i see it's like a firework of curls in
the firework of curls
baby you're a curve working
come on let them curls twerks so it's so
curly yeah
i got i'm the i'm the steven seagal this
is what i call mine
but thank you for saying a guy there you
go um
all right narage krishnan here oh
underrated thank you narage what's he
got we got
ben foster great monster great freaking
creepy [ __ ] ben foster
yeah creepy except for when he's a
beautiful pre-teen angel
uh we gotta cancel viggo mortensen he
played a puerto rican in carlito's way
oh that's right okay uh speaking of
which
al pacino played a cuban into puerto
rican and he's not we gotta cancel him
okay that's the way these things work
right
i mean i plan to just i played a mexican
character in university
studios once so i should be canceled i
shouldn't
okay you should be cancelled viggo morse
i'm just trying to judge up everyone's
past all right yeah i'm just trying
i'm trying to do the work for you guys
well they say that you know
all moments are happening simultaneously
so really your past is your presence
really it's omnipresent
you should be judged on your past okay
tony colette
oh tony colette [ __ ] yeah tony
underrated forever since uh hereditary
got snubbed and then olivia wilde
which uh yeah yeah yeah i haven't seen
like the full extent of olivia wilde's
more
uh in-depth acting work but i do cowboys
and aliens
definitely man she's so good in there
the change up
i love those movies both with all my
heart she's great for five minutes in
her
with the already shouted out scarlett
johansson and rooney mars underrated too
but tony collette uh yeah i agree with
that ben
foster [ __ ] he's he plays great
villains
310 to yuma was brought up as an
underrated film last week and he's
underrated in that performance
and viggo mortensen i i think the
collaboration efforts of viego mortensen
and david cronenberg combined
are just an underrated duo generally
speaking
vegan said yeah he's like he's not the
most marketable actor in the world and
yet he's done like er
like you i guess i would assume that
because he was aragorn he ought to be
like
super highly rated but yeah i mean he
still pops up in like small characters i
mean a lot of people didn't really know
his name until
until that movie and i feel like they've
gotten it when you get that big off of
like a specific franchise like that
people often only associate you with
that
role yeah so they have a harder time
really branching i mean [ __ ] kristen
st
robert pattinson has he's still kind of
the toilet guy in some people's eyes
but but he at least gets a lot of
defenders whereas kristen stewart is
still in that twilight era
i mean daniel radcliffe that's great
daniel radcliffe i think he's actually
an underrated actor i would agree he
still gets along you know
he's just [ __ ] harry potter for the
rest of his life that's your fault
daniel
why'd you have to make so much money
being harry potter yeah yeah yeah
ethan holgate is next jk rowling
underrated author
everyone loves jk am i saying the right
things oh yeah and she loves everyone
and that's what's important that's what
i hear about her she she's not trying to
uh separate a group of people who are
already struggling for their legitimacy
from that legitimacy i don't know what
you're talking about oh
go you know go read a tweet
which is the easily the one i enjoyed
out of all those movies i didn't enjoy
ethan holgate
welcome to our super chat section okay
welcome to the chaos
jim caviezel is a super rad underrated
actor in my opinion
i agree the [ __ ] learned aramaic
for passion of the christ and he speaks
it fluently every day since
he played the son of dennis quaid in
frequency
he is not the guy he is the guy in the
count of money
he's i was thinking of guy pierce yes
yes but i'm like wait is guy pierson
count of monte cristo
i think so it's guy pierce and jim
caviezel i think so [ __ ] guy pierce
is an underrated actor wait
somebody i think christian marquez
pointed out guy pierce oh just recently
yeah yeah yeah that's a good call it's a
good call yeah
jane caviezel who was also in the show
person of interest with another
underrated actor michael emerson
who is friggin terrific very good call
yeah
very cool makes the tv circuit more than
the film but still
terriff thank you ethan holgate ooh
dominic
zephyr thank you dominic sexy name now
this is just objective truth
john say the super chat in the voice of
the actor he is referencing
uh dominic zefera you express yourself
and you say that underrated actor tommy
was so
he expressed himself he don't hurt
anyone and if you don't know the answer
you just see the room 200 time
and you know the answer next question
thank you dominic very underrated uh
existence
are you being safe lanae you're in texas
right now i know it's kind of scary
you're in more the smaller town of texas
so i can understand if you're
not as concerned but are your
grandparents okay haven't heard from you
in a while
oh here we go underrated actor jensen
ackles ooh my bloody valentine hells
yeah 3d
actress leticia wright black panther not
bad
overrated actor tom hardy
and actress brie larson my own opinion
oh i think bree larson's over oh i was
thinking allison brie
yeah crazy bree larson is that famous
she's [ __ ] gary marvel and i'm like
how is him now from global really yeah
yeah
uh is brie larson
i i feel like everyone hates wheelers
that's funny because
last week we did overrated movies and
people say cat tomorrow i'm like i don't
want to do that i don't
think things that are not a great empty
yeah
um i would say underrated movie but yeah
uh i would
i mean i can't really meet you on the
tom i
one thing i i did a one-on-one match
with dan merle in movie fights where i
fought for tom hardy as the greatest
actor working a day
and he fought for emily blunt the
greatest actor working today
and he said something that i had to
maneuver around
and i've come to find out it's true uh
and
to a certain extent because he's done
some kind he does he
shows off some comedic chops in uh venom
and he was in the romantic comedy this
means war
uh much beloved uh but
tom hardy i he tends to consistently go
for the heavy
and he he doesn't really and he always
tries to
he tends to do work where the spotlight
is really on him
like even if it's a supporting role you
know like he goes so heavy all the time
i don't agree that's always the case
with the guy
um and i could see if you think he's
overrated like
i personally can't meet you there
because i think he's
one of those two good and i think he's
one of the top three working actors
today
yeah i i guess i would only i would say
overrated in the sense that there are
times where i'm like we
do we don't have to pitch him for every
new year you know
there are other actors than tom hardy
even though he's great and i think
everyone
on supernatural for the most part is an
underrated performer
jensen ackles especially and leticia
wright
i honestly i'm only familiar with her in
black panther i feel like i might have
seen her in something else that i had
it's not coming to mind right now i sort
of feel like at least in my experience
and hey if she's got hella roles that
are great please let me know but i feel
like to
to me she just isn't in the position
to be over or underrated just yet you
know i feel like she
did great in black panther i really
enjoyed her presence there i'm looking
forward to seeing more performances from
her
so uh yeah i don't know in a weird way
like i can definitely see why
you would say underrated for sure but uh
and then let's go to
uh all right but thank you lynette
appreciate you being here mission
your name all right let's do three to
five more here and then we're gonna go
back to your guys's comments to see what
you guys are saying
i also want to throw out pedro pascal i
think very underrated actor underrated
especially
for all of his physical performing in
the mandalorian
chill level tv what's up buddy what it
do underrated bruce campbell
sung king who oh that's some suggestion
he's a good actor yeah foxy's so good
the [ __ ] um why am i thinking of the
movie right now
one of my favorite movies it won the
oscar for both categories
why can't i have a parasite
wait yeah yeah yeah
oh wait wait am i getting did i get the
name wrong
let's let's i'll i'll google it because
i sometimes get the name wrong with
the fast and furious tokyo trip guys
that's who we're talking about
han my friend yeah wait a minute wait
you guys just correct me in the comments
because i said you guys got those names
wrong
but is it no [ __ ] um i thought i
wrote
i knew i should have imdb'd it but i
just wrote down sun kang on my list
i gotta be i gotta be clear about this
he's in bullet to the head
he's in uh he's in uh let's see here we
got he's in an episode of family guy
it uh no no no i got the name wrong my
bad
but yeah and han's coming back i just
put sucking
on my list thinking it was the guy from
parasite but it's gone
kong ho's song you can see how you can
get that jumbled in your head
yes yes in fact i i may have made this
very mistake
because he's also in training to busan
and uh yeah yeah
that's that i got it all right anyway
bruce campbell
yes underappreciated actor absolutely i
don't know sam clark at least in
in in mainstream i would say and in the
horror community i feel like bruce
campbell is doing
a all right fine chris campbell was a
major influence on jim carrey in case
you guys didn't know that jim carrey
often
references bruce campbell as a big
source of inspiration for
the kind of comedy that he decided to do
and like mir and then actually when
watching
evil dead 2 and army of darkness i see a
lot of jim carrey mannerisms
apes from the kind of facial expressions
bruce campbell would do in there
it's funny sam claflin i i felt the need
to look him up because i have heard this
guy's name thrown out in underrated and
and
you know sort of like who should play
this new person i've heard this guy's
name checked a bunch of times
and uh all i've seen him in is the
hunger games
he's he's uh he's the the sexy guy maybe
he's on a show or something that we just
don't know about
but yeah i keep hearing his name so i'm
gonna keep an eye out for the man
claflin
uh jordan metz is next thank you jordan
metz thank you how about those mets
uh underrated britney murphy rest in
peace
and benicio del toro you know
benicio did take i mean rest in peace
brittany murphy
i always think of sin city when i think
of brittany every single time
you think i go to eight miles i go to
fandom for [ __ ]
for eminem i go to to sin city
then i go to clueless then i go to eight
miles um yeah
but benicio del toro i really thought
benicio del toro
would be like [ __ ] like i thought he
would reach
in the latino market of like
what wherever antonio banderas did in
the 90s you know
oh yeah and but benitor i mean he won
the oscar for traffic
and then uh he's done a lot of smaller
films since
and you'd think he'd be bigger now like
with the fact that he is in the last
jedi and he's in guardian galaxy or the
avengers
marvel verse but yeah i i do think he's
a rather underrated actor because
he does most of his like great impactful
work now is in the smaller projects
yeah um but yeah i mean i agree i agree
jordan metz thank you buddy yeah benicio
too like he has a lot of
like i'll never forget the story i heard
about uh
the usual suspects uh brian singer but
uh but yeah like he created that role
and
and when he first showed up speaking the
way he did in that movie people like
what is he doing
you know like and then that became sort
of an iconic thing so i i've associated
him over time with
you know those kinds of quirky decisions
so i think he's got a lot of talent and
range that
yeah doesn't necessarily get touched on
the mainstream but he's able to like
be in the mainstream just as often as he
wants to it's like
sexy in a weird way in that like
beleaguered kind of way
like weird and creepy and tired and
you're sexy
i don't get it but you like you you
shouldn't be
sexy but you're sexy benicio del toro
hey man
he's the bull he's the bull um pj
panda some
other underrated actors that i enjoy
robert
pattinson well okay you know what
if he does well in batman and people
love him then people are going to say
he's overrated he'll immediately
it's hard to find that balance so just
just go there
yeah right daniel absolutely underrated
man
from the first time i saw him that guy
left an impression on me a lot of people
still know him as
the guy from get out uh like they don't
really know his name
they don't know him as the guy from
black mirror maybe he's great
black mirror season uh season one yeah
second episode right yeah
incredible in that uh and he's you know
he's also in black panther of course
but daniel kaluya whoa i mean just his
performance alone and get out all right
we just want to isolate it if you wanted
to
deduct the other things we named his
performance alone and get out is enough
to
warrant him as like a top-tier actor for
sure uh i totally agree
john david washington dude when tenant
comes out
in july 15th no wait no if it comes out
july 31
when it comes on august 12th no uh
january 2022
you'll see he's gonna be a super he's
gonna be overrated when that comes out
yeah absolutely man no yeah he's great
uh riley reed underrated porn actress
for sure
samara weaving uh hugo weavey's daughter
she is related to her weaving who's
riley cough riley keough
uh she was just in the lodge i've seen
her in bit parts but she's um
yeah she's definitely like a a recent
kind of successful
is she and i'm not familiar with her
yeah yeah you've probably
seen her face okay yeah i heard the
lodge was pretty good so um
i don't know yeah i don't know much
about her right like elvis presley's
granddaughter
but i believe oh there you go and samara
weaving i believe is actually related to
hugo leaving
oh yeah i was kind of worried samara
weaving would get like discount margot
robbie talk
and maybe now i'm just inciting that but
she's
she is a [ __ ] phenomenal have you
seen ready or not
no john john you call yourself the
horror movie guys i know
radio style not seen ready or not
i haven't seen radio silences ready or
not no i haven't what the [ __ ] john
those guys are those that that those
directors are making the next scream
movie
oh that's right yeah yeah from vhs to to
john yeah you should watch it it's good
i want to see it i didn't get to see it
in theaters uh but keanu reeves is
overrated in my
opinion what the [ __ ] are you talking
about i will be kidding you i will kill
you
i will do the antithesis to a keanu
reeves or dude you in this yeah
i will not lead to go by his example uh
i i can honestly see why some
like i love keanu reeves i've i've never
found
like that like a great actor because
he's only great in like specific kind of
roles
yeah um but i think
the thing you can't argue with is keanu
reeves the person
is the greatest human being walking the
earth
as we speak right now he's impossible to
top
you okay john yeah i read a comment that
distracted me i apologize of course you
did
but yeah that's all thank you buddy and
then one more then we're gonna see what
you guys are saying here
pig penis mrh nice i love that name
pig penis is totally underrated as most
south korean actors are
old boy and i saw the devil were
fantastic remember the octopus eating in
a one-shot
fight yes i do oh man that's a very
vulnerable performance that he gives in
uh
an old boy very very vulnerable
performance and um
yeah josh brolin had nothing on him on
the remake of old boy
so thank you for pointing that out yeah
there's i mean south korea has a lot of
incredible actors and
not enough of them get get enough praise
seriously
and i i'm hoping parasite does something
to make
more south korean films more uh have a
bigger spotlight in the states
yeah because i mean like south korea has
been turning out some intense and
really heavy heavy-duty cinema for a
long time there's a master
like disturbing horror for sure yeah
yeah
let's see here all right so then we got
okay
let's see what you guys are saying in
the chat ooh i saw let's see
underrated michael keaton john krasinski
underrated is michael keane underrated
on a bag of michael keaton
uh i saw one kim basinger was
underrated apparently yeah
she was let's do that not anymore who
will be overrated in the future and
who's on their way to being underrated
uh johnny depp versus leonardo d versus
rdj i mean they're all great you know uh
andrew lincoln
is thank you tyler for saying that
andrew lincoln is very
very much underrated actor yeah he's got
chops for days
i always forget that that is not his
real voice whenever i watch any of the
walking dead
you watch love actually again and you're
like whoa i i watch
an interview with andrew lincoln and i'm
like
this doesn't sound right yeah
right like it seems off that he sounds
yeah all the dust is gone when he's
speaking in his normal voice he speaks
to his normal voice so i'm like
why are you doing this accent uh
guy pierce underrated for sure uh let's
see here
marlon brando on rarity i don't think
marlon brando is over underrated
william fichner there's one greg if you
like cameron monahan i hope you have
seen shameless nah i'm just talking
about today i haven't seen shameless
a lot of people recommend it to me
though nicholas cage overrated ryan
reynolds will be an overrated actor
if ryan reynolds doesn't start branching
out
more with the kind of roles he does like
he needs to do like another kind of
you know buried movie here because right
now he's showing up and just being ryan
reynolds in almost everything he's doing
and he needs to branch out a little bit
more
or else he will enter into overrated
territory
seth rogen is one where for a time i
think he did spend some time overrated
but especially when his career started
to mature and he started taking more
like roll rolls
uh he's i think he's underrated i think
he's got some chops
uh i mean he yes in terms of acting he's
kind of
he's the same kind of guy every time but
he's a caliber of talent all around like
he's great writer and director as well
and uh so i think like seth rogen is
just underrated in that department i
think the
filmmaker seth rogen is underrated he
deserves more credit
shelbin khan is a very underrated
character actress
and thank you mark lee she just named
someone on my list logan marshall green
more than discount tom hardy he's
actually incredible
you already did you name maria seahorn
or somebody else named ria seahorn
making sure it was the same actress from
better call saul
you know there are a lot of names flying
around i don't know if you know i
remember everyone
uh ryan reynolds on the edge of being
over somebody uh somebody pointed
out jake gyllenhaal i think there's a a
an interesting argument to be made oh hi
victor sullivan you said hi to us a
minute ago
i think jake gyllenhaal is is on his way
to being raided
because for a minute there he was
definitely underrated when he really
started to throw down on like bigger
more performance
heavy more vulnerable roles but i feel
like
especially in a post spider-man world
we're nearing the point where he could
become that superstar gyllenhaal because
also like
he's a heartthrob like a lot of people
are just in love with jake
so uh ryan gosling and jake gyllenhaal
both underappreciated i think ryan
gosling
um i i don't think people really know
why to
appreciate ryan gosling to the degree
they should
just [ __ ] incredible uh blake lively
has uh definitely upped her acting game
michael mckeon who is i mean like better
call saul yeah for sure but he's also
gotten
like huge amounts of comedy cred under
his belt with uh christopher guest and
all that stuff he's
great i got one rebecca ferguson i think
is a very underrated actress
oh wow daniel jones greg's hair
overrated you want to fight
do you want to go in a ponytail it's not
it's like it's not as good my brother
prefers me in a ponytail apparently
logan lerman underrated jason dolan
uh you know who's also underrated adam
sandler in dramas
[Music]
he really is he really is aaron paul
underrated what would we say about about
aaron paul
yeah yeah i'd say no a lot of people
don't recognize him as being the
the the caliber of talent that he really
is
like he's he he can sometimes be aaron
paul but i feel like just his ability to
emote and be vulnerable is like
so huge that it doesn't necessarily
matter to me
i got two bald actors who are underrated
stanley tucci and mark strong
hey oh mark's wrong for sure those two
look like brothers
they should play brothers one day they
should start on the remake of brothers
dude
perfect call them bald brothers oh
the brother brothers oh see you got some
love john's hair is overrated greg's
hair is better
is the better hair so that's not true
andy circus
daniel's chair john's hair is his normal
rage
it's it's yeah it's fine it's it's you
know i'll take
i'll take rated i've seen angelina jolie
on a lot of lists of
of being overrated actress and yeah i
mean i
there was a time she won the oscar
rightfully so and she's done a lot of
great movies but she kind of just did
become like
action heroine character around and
i'm like but you've got more than that
man i i haven't seen any of the movie
she's directed and i'm at fault for that
jackie chan
is actually an underrated actor thank
you i can't uh mimi
what is it mirna uh jackie chan is like
as an actor not just the action
performer and
comedy performer the actor jackie chan
is actually a very underrated actor
james mcavoy a little underrated i'll
give you that rdj
overrated says tyler slavin right
jennifer lawrence i've actually seen
more jennifer lawrence overrated in this
chat but just a kessler is
underrated a lot of people hate jennifer
lawrence i know katie seagal this was
the one that fascinated me sam
samuel stokes katie seagal is very
underrated just watch married with
children
and sons of anarchy which you know two
very different flavors from her
yeah all right guys uh one more and then
uh
darren chris i saw play hedwig and head
rigging in the angry inch at the
pantages
thank you for the hard degree yeah we
did mention bill hader we didn't mention
bill here
um okay i think we got another stream
lab here that we should
we definitely acknowledge got to get
this dream labs
all right he said in his tarid scottish
accent
oh john john bear with me john oh you're
great
oh there you go there you go there you
go there you go
doing it i'm doing i'm putting it on
screen john
i'm doing the technical [ __ ] i'm doing
the technical [ __ ]
i'm doing it okay thank you eric
horseman
good night mark leech be safe buddy be
well and safe and all
thank you eric uh ana torv
oh and fringe also a totally underrated
show and mind hunter love her now go
watch
fringe oh she the girl from mine hunter
i guess so yeah she's blonde
did you not see mine hunter i've seen
the first season of mine tundra
she's not the second the she's not i
think she's yeah i think she's the uh
the main john don't you see what you're
doing to the screen oh
wow i'm so sorry i gotta look her up
i'll look her up on the phone john don't
worry
you're not able to be patient and you
get carried away with yourself
that's right she is the girl she's the
other uh psychologist character a mind
hunter
she's [ __ ] incredible in that show
yeah she is she's great yeah
yeah yeah as a matter of fact i think
all those actors on mine hunter
i don't know their name especially
especially uh who plays holt he's
[ __ ]
that's the one yeah yeah yeah if you
guys
it's not going to get a third season
unfortunately i can't believe my hunter
uh yeah my uh [ __ ] everyone on my hunter
is great pretty much anyone who's worked
in a david fincher property
but you don't know their name is a great
actor yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the guy's
name deny ryan oh no it's late in the uk
holt's mccalleny that's his name
who plays tench oh yeah the actor's name
is
and then jonathan graff yeah is that oh
god yeah
all right but thank you eric horseman
for bringing that but yeah i mean mine
hunter and
thank you for your major super chat dude
um
but yeah i think uh i i think uh mine
hunter generally is a
very underrated show dude oh yeah very
underrated tote bags thank you so much
oh dude i'm so sorry but uh i i gotta i
gotta i gotta call out this name
go for it timothy oliphant honest
underrated such a good actor such a
funny too
hilarious all right guys let's see how
well how much do we got
left yeah but this is great you guys are
i mean lately we've been lucky with the
wait wait wait sterling k brown sterling
cable just set it in here marvin
thank you marvin sterling kane brown
[Laughter]
yes yes yes oh we got a pacino overrated
look out al pacino is not overrated
he does the best cuban accent jack
shawasha oscar
huh you [ __ ] with me
i could listen to an audiobook reading
that book and then his puerto rican
accent in carlito's way
i grew up man
tranquilo tranquilo man oh
god did you just touch my hand i am in
love with you now
brendan v how are you doing brendan v
thank you i
mentioned it earlier thank you brendan v
the pizza neon go
or overrated i had a feeling he come up
in this live stream at some point
i'm surprised more people haven't
brought him up i thought he i thought
more people would bring him up oh night
mimi
um i know you got a lot of guys in like
europe and the uk who are here in our
live stream go to bed if you must please
um chris pratt is
overrated side note watch airplane for
the first time this week and watching
the lighthouse tonight
love you studs love you too brendan v
you know honestly like i love me some
chris pratt i really do
but then once in a while he does kind of
teeter into
you're kind of getting on my it's the
right
there was a time where i was like chris
pratt yes and then once
i'm like uh get him out of the spotlight
a little bit
you know i agree i gotta i i have to say
that you know like
i don't always love chris pratt yeah
he's he's he's a bit on the
overrated side for me personally
actually as well
we'll go into it more jon hammer at home
tell the audience you need to because
he has a super chat thank you i know
that's more important under
christine kristen stewart finally an
underrated kristen stewart
on the record overrated sam jackson
don't hate me
i like him now what the hell are you
talking about he has a wide range
of delivery in all his movies
no i'm not yelling that's how i talk hey
you seen my movies
i love sam jackson but i guess i could
never argue either way
i mean he always shows up he always
shows up i don't know him to phone it in
i think even when he's phoning in and
he's just good at it even when he's just
doing the sam jackson thing he always
look
he is a man of work ethic that's the
thing with sam jackson
he show he's he has that kind of old
school mentality
that all actors should honestly adopt of
like i'm being paid to do a job
so i'm gonna do my job you know and sam
jackson i think
always delivers a thousand percent
always delivers man
but no i mean does he have a wide range
not
usually but once in a while he'll show
up and be like [ __ ] he just did a
he's a great he's like the great version
of nick cage
it's like he's always it's like he's
loud eccentric
he's kind of does the same thing a lot
of the time but the difference is he
picks better movies
and he's always good you know that
that's the main difference with the guy
i don't know i think one's white and the
other guy's black i think that's another
big difference
i don't know why this popped into my
head but before we move on uh
verner herzog very underrated actor yes
and person all around underrated xander
whatever
name is xander hornaday xander hernandez
and a hornady
make me gay with them straight away
made me gay when i was born again silent
bob and james
underrated cameron monahan overrated
margot
robbins put them together in a movie
though let's see how that turns out
cameron did you just put cameron
monahan's joker
in the [ __ ] dc there was a song right
there okay
and then margot robbie open the
multiverse margot robbie
i used the new pirates i can say it i
can get it if you don't like her harley
quinn you think are harley quinn's
overrated
but the actress margot robbie she's done
a lot of great [ __ ] work man
like wolf of wall street i taunt just
look at wolf of wall street and i tonya
those two movies right there
incredible actors oh seriously oh yeah
uh
but if you think she's overrated i can
actually see where you're coming from a
little bit
for the amount of hype and maybe the
amount of fame that she
is i mean she's all she is that case
though where she's like
like if you just look if you don't know
margot robbie the actress you look at
her she's like a
gorgeous woman and then she ends up
being this exceptionally talented
actress at the same time
yeah right um but yeah uh that's true
dream chaser thank you dream chaser glad
to see you back in our super chats buddy
and we are not tired of you because
these are not tardy
dude hi guys hope you're not tired of me
though overrated actor
dwayne johnson i think his charisma does
all the heavy lifting
which i mean these days can that be
overrated though
can can the amount of charisma the man
there's actually
something to be said for that because
not a lot of actors nowadays can
consistently
churn out big movies and big properties
based solely on their charisma alone you
it's like
you can't just say like [ __ ] tom
cruise because tom cruise comes from
like
the 80s you know yeah yeah like those
kind of actors like brad pitt and
dicaprio in the 90s like
i mean dicaprio has more range than
doing johnson but
but you know like those actors
who primarily work off of their charisma
are kind of from an earlier era yeah
not many actors who are in the last
decade become superstars
primarily hone in on their charisma yeah
so i think there's something to be said
to the fact that dwayne johnson
primarily works off of his charisma
and it seems to be panning out well for
the guy you know i feel like he can do
things without the charisma but the
charisma just does so much
that it makes a fruit it's very true
that's very true
elba well be late to the stream but
underrated killian murphy no qualms here
no clumps at all killing murphy was the
first penis i ever saw in a theater
not in 28 days later i was at a theater
and killing him
there with his dick out just like why
are you touching yourself during the
dark night screaming
he's a normal theater jesus christ man
put it away
go downtown for that no it was that's
the first movie ever
first first penis ever saw the i i
honestly
i mean what year did 28 days later come
out was that like 2001 or something like
that or
i didn't know you could show penises in
movies that's how young i was when i saw
that in theaters
i didn't know you could even show a
penis in a theater in a movie
and uh that was like the first time i
saw it i was like there's a penis on
screen
yeah and then it is funny to look back
and think like oh wow the presence of
male nudity always did seem like a whoa
what's happening uh so you know
underrated penis
underrated thank google that
you got freezed tom peltry
no pelfree ozark season three
google thomas
not tom petty and then funny enough uh
ozark
is like the autofill for it this guy is
charming i've never seen him before i
don't think unless he was on
this isn't the guy thank you you got
freeze this is the guy from iron fist
oh he's on iron fist oh he's ward he's
wart
ward yeah see the same ward from [ __ ]
agents of shield no that is uh brett
dalton
no i'm saying right is the same
character i don't
i don't think so i don't think so
but but i could be mistaken grant ward i
just don't think that he would
knowing what i know about agents of
shield's plot line and what i know about
the iron fist plot line and who i think
i
remember seeing him as on screen i just
don't think it would make any sense
because
isn't he the one with the sister and the
reason i'm not sure to be honest
but yeah hey we got a yellow dollar bill
sign on this video already
dude well we're live we got a yellow
dollar bill
listen all right making ad revenue is
overrated
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] okay now let's
really hammer that one home
vagina but thank you you got freeze nice
to see you here
oh john john too fast too fast it jumped
on me
sultan comedy chris evans and robert
downey jr but the question is
under or overrated i'm pretty sure he's
saying they're over
sultan comedy love your name by the way
no would it be great to be a sultan
yeah a sultan of swing most certainly i
think
um chris evans and robert downey jr
honestly if our rdj deserves respect
forever
has he gotten canceled yet for all this
blackface stuff no but it's come up it's
because it's satire
the thing because it's making fun yeah
the thing with that was it's making fun
of how wrong the black face is
yeah yeah and it's an example of satire
that does
translate i'm just trying to see what's
properly woke
it's not one of those satire moments i
have a discussion where someone
live stream on youtube who's caught
being insensitive and then goes oh no
no no it was satire they're like
i think rdj gets a pass because everyone
was aware at the time
um chris evans i actually think is an
underrated actor
like the actor chris the actor yeah he's
he
he's got a wide like him stepping away
from captain america
while there's a sadness to be had with
that it excited me because i also know
that the guy is like he he has a much
bigger range of talent than
only like captain america and um i mean
right away [ __ ] did knives out
and showed like remember douchey chris
evans
sushi chris evans was awesome
pcp's back pcp cult
pop culture not gonna lie i recently
tried shrooms
oh dude well how was it how was it man
did you enjoy your experience
he's in michigan he's can get kind of
bored out there
tell me how is your shroom's experience
dude and tell me
is is don't breathe realistic
you live in michigan eric horstmann
ooh thank you eric horseman thank you
buddy for contributing again
you can stop now eric thank you it is
more than more than enough
underrated issa rae and the entire cast
of insecure
i agree just season f uh just finished
season four best show
ever shout out to yvonne orgy and
natasha roth well
that is a show with a great cast and i'm
always happy to see uh
even though you know besides easter ray
a lot of the people have shown up in
like you know
horror movies like uh escape room or or
a purge sequel you know like all the
actors on that show do have a lot of
chops and
uh i i i'm behind but uh it's terrific
so yeah i i support that 100 dude eric
horseman
always got great picks hey buy victor
sullivan easter egg also good in the
photograph
with the stanfield uh
let's see here and then yeah there's
something a lot of left for vincent
d'onofrio in the chat right now keep it
going
guys keep it going this is not for you
keep that off rio
michael b my homeboy from virginia omni
media killing her right now with doom
patrol reactions on his channel
underrated kaya scott delario
and mary elizabeth winstead she married
elizabeth winston for sure let me look
up guys
adam brody david ramsey this guy
loves his fox and cw michael clark
duncan yes
and james marston you know james martin
does deserve a lot more
he is delightful but he said that he
doesn't ever want to get that famous
like too famous that's why he started
sonic the hedgehog
that's right you know i
from his level it's too famous is a is a
yeah i don't know i mean he's already
pretty freaking famous
um but let's who's kaya scott delario
okay so um i have seen her in one movie
that i am absolutely aware of and she
was great in it which was
crawl uh the uh spooky alligator movie
by
alexander aja which she and barry pepper
pretty much have to carry
and she did do a terrific job so i i do
have to give it to her in that movie
um so this is what she looks like yeah
that girl right there that girl
okay right oh what i have is right there
no i was a good point is
that one there's a good yeah there you
go face shots that's what we're doing
crawl underrated 2019 motion picture
mary elizabeth winstead will be a
superstar one day
i'm calling her right now she will be
she's been putting in the work for so
much time now like i think she deserves
she's the much wider range of talent
there's like zoe de chanel and then
there's the
the more talented version of zoe de
chanel in the acting apartment and
that's mary elizabeth winstead
sure i'll go with you on that well they
both kind of have that like dry
personality but then she can do a much
much more wider range of genres
that's true too you know i i will
definitely
agree with you there james mcavoy
underrated according to shazi boy in the
chat
seth macfarlane there you go he's kind
of underrated
he can be and in fact yeah especially in
i wish he would do
more stuff like hellboy the golden army
fair enough because like he was legit
right
i mean he was just a voiceover in that
though he didn't do the actual bodywork
that's true but he
he sank into a character in a way that
i am not often used to him doing
if that makes sense uh brendan v back in
the chat thank you buddy
we're gonna try to end this live stream
in like 20 minutes
yeah um just by the way
this is a heads up um but thank you
everyone who's been here if you're here
please hit that like button it makes a
big difference especially when we got
yellow dollar bill signs
helps keep us uncensored when we're
talking on this stream
the brendan v thank you dude regardless
of ann's
is that ansel elgort no it's angel
eggert
[Laughter]
still excited for was that my contacts
are drying out
wss so excited for wss just trying to
focus on rachel zegler getting her big
break
and all the other amazingly talented
broadway people in the cast is that like
uh
is that some i
[Music]
they're kind of limited to how many
characters you can put which is annoying
uh oh wss that's a shoe store oh yeah
warehouse shoe sale
oh ansel elgort with being canceled
recently is opening up a shoe store
that's right that's right definitely i
mean yes i'm very excited
i'm very excited for it man for ansel
elgort's juice
what would he call his shoe company
that's what i want to know west side
story i was gonna say it had to be
something huge
how did i not put that together your
west side story
yeah i mean i guess i'm worried for west
side story now but uh
uh i do wear a contacts daniel jones uh
yeah
man uh stephen steven spielberg take on
a classic musical so is
is is ansel elgort on this just
retracted that context question
is is ansel elgort on the jets or the
shark side uh
probably the jets i don't know are you
sure no i'm not at all sores
which one is which um you know whichever
one
sam uh sam worthington no ansel ogortz
on that's that's probably the jets
the new york jets that's right it's a
football movie
yeah and then they play the sharks from
hockey because it's about crossing over
it's about what if the football team
took on the hockey team
yeah i don't know why it's called west
side story
it's a story that takes place in the
west every place is west of some place
yo
in the chat christopher padger right now
saying sarah paulson is underrated
i gotta agree yeah she's terrific she
can also kind of be annoying sometimes
but when she's not she's [ __ ]
incredible she's getting into rated
territory because of american horror
story but she's still got helichops and
lily rape does too speaking of american
horror story
also underrated is uh uh speaking of
angela bassett if you watch i know she's
done other seasons
she's in therapy with dylan mcdermott in
the first season but the woman who plays
the
real life counterpart of the angela
bassett character in the roanoke season
that that woman that actress is terrific
and i've seen her and stuff i don't know
her names
but uh she's yeah she's great um
let's see here and then of course of
course
we got love for uh uh i lost it
i lost it i mean there's a lot of brian
in this chat
and danny trejo being overrated uh
wow who are they saying is over
christian bale i'm seeing a lot of talk
about christian bale in the chat
i don't think he's overrated i don't
think he's gotten like the
res i i feel like he's actually an
unappreciated actor to be honest
christian bale yeah yeah i can get
behind that
um like he like yeah he's got great
chops but in terms of like being
i feel like terminator salvation was his
opportunity to get overrated if that
movie had been good in success
fair enough all right so let's see here
where are we at
will heron underrated and maybe a hot
take
dramatic adam samuel yeah that's what i
said uncut
punch drug lug meyer wit stories is one
of the best actors working today
dude throwing funny people [ __ ]
incred like adam sandler is a great
traumatic actor
and throw in um the what's the one where
he lost his family in 9 11 rain on fire
rain on me
all right that wasn't even reign of fire
that was a dragon
joke that was
that's the kind of insensitive like it's
a kind of insensitive [ __ ]
fantasy movie instead of reimagining
history tarantino style going what would
have been better if hitler had been
blown up or if charlie manson's people
had just been
beating the [ __ ] up like yeah just do
that that's like that
[ __ ] hillary duff sharon tate
premonition horror movie
[ __ ] yeah
but yeah i agree with you dude i brought
that up earlier but thank you will
god that feels a bad idea mr neon gtp
thank you for being here dude
oh thank you so much you two are my
favorite reaction duo on youtube we
learned all from dwayne and jazz so
thank you buddy
uh keep it up you're dwayne i'm jeff
thanks i want you to know that oh take
it yeah let's take a dynamic
i'll take it for sure but thank you dude
i really that means a lot thank you
manuel rodriguez what are you doing
john why are you because i'm a racist
perfectly creepy green goblin
for sam remy man
i'll be over here down here oh
you dig the hole it's all right some
people think i'm latinos so it works to
my
it works it's not it's not racist it's
so racist
i mean there is uh some of that
influence in the filipino culture no
where do you think you can get off
talking about the filipino culture chunk
you know
i i i include myself in it just because
my best friend is
a lot of people love karaoke yeah but
filipinos had it first
we invented to carry on we [ __ ] no we
we did i'm throwing
hold on let me put the super chats away
i'm gonna tell you guys about karaoke
we filipinos have karaoke
at our gatherings we like buy the
[ __ ] programs and dvds
and we have it in our homes okay all of
us
now so we don't have to go to some
[ __ ] bar or some [ __ ] to do it okay
yeah we don't need we don't need that
anyway let's bring it back here all
right let's go back to stream labs
because we got a couple more in the
stream
labs john you lost
i'm so flipping i'm so
[ __ ] sorry name that real reject
sketch all right here we go we got
hitman hudson oh thank you underrated
actress this is one you've argued for in
movie fights
jessica she should have been supergirl
she is underrated like she's
so good in those happy days love jessica
ross she's a [ __ ] incredible actress
oh underrated actor greg alba as jackson
maine during the showdown
free-for-all i just want to take one
last look at you
bradley cooper john i want you to know
that this is a
it's a good live stream
i don't want to come home and find you
later bradley cooper as jackson maine
giving an inferior performance
as compared to greg alvarez that is a
funny comment
that is a truthful way to go man bradley
cooper's performance and
screenshot my girlfriend hates bradley
cooper and then when she was watching
[ __ ] uh star wars born in the theater
she had to look over at me and go
oh my god i think i'm in love with
bradley yes you win
like halfway through that movie
vindicated
and oh eric horseman thank you so much
just to
[ __ ] you to the yellow thank you
thank you thank you eric horseman for
looking at those uptight advertisers who
also
pay us and that yeah i take it back
we're beholden to them
uh let's see here okay anyway man well
we're no we didn't properly read this
comment thank you manuel
manuel emanuel rodriguez
william defoey perfect creepy green
goblin for sam raimi
jump scare by green goblin and i would
like to see
daiquiri montgomery and more roles after
stranger things season three
yeah i was impressed with power rangers
okay
stranger things did nothing for me it
was all about the red ranger
in power range the way he showed that
one guy at detention and then saved the
world
okay that's it that's a great way of how
to handle diversity you make your main
guy
still white make everyone else ethnic
that's how you do it i love that let's
do that
that's how it works that sounds like the
right way to do this
that's how you do it man
guys kravitz i'm either sarcastic in the
way
of how i'm making fun of the fact of how
that's wrong
or i'm sarcastic in the way of making
fun of the people who think that's wrong
either way whoever loses i win
best taglines in movie history zoe
kravitz has retracted what the [ __ ] zoe
kravitz has attracted her first message
i always knew that actress was a [ __ ]
god damn it i mean i don't want to say
anything but the case is holy crap
in case it's the real zoey crap oh no
then they made it up it made us okay
thank you zoey kravitz thank you
thank you in fact that's the real zoey
kravitz you're a cheap ass [ __ ]
person
i'm not gonna comment in case it is okay
it's not the real
zoey kravitz honestly zoe kravitz is an
actress who
like every time i see her i'm like she's
doing a good job
i feel like i ought to like and be
clicking with her i can't click
i don't know why i i feel like you wait
till she's
personally overrated i guarantee you
when she does catwoman she's gonna be
people are she's people are gonna put
her up there as one of the great guys
make a timer on this live stream right
now
as the day greg declared that she is
gonna be one of the best like
she's gonna be up there with like i
don't know who's better michelle
pfeiffer or zoey kravitz
there's going to be a hard debate that
comes when zoe cross oh yeah
i guarantee you she's going to add
michelle pfeiffer out for sure
no i watch guys watch now if i'm wrong
i'm going to go into the youtube editor
and delete this out of the live stream
that's how confident i am in my own
opinions
that's inspiring gee that's really
inspiring dolan
dolan is that our man now kyle chandler
jason bateman jason siegel underrated
kyle chandler especially i think jason
bateman is actually pretty rated right
now it goes
in it it goes okay the most overrated
i mean most underrated underrated most
underrated kyle chandler than the the
second most underrated jason siegel and
then jason bateman he's
just he's got ozark and every year
everyone tells me that i have to watch
it yeah
oh mimi's back um and then let's see
here but thank you dolan uh yeah jason
siegel
uh underrated writer as well jason sigel
underwriter
yeah zoey kravitz is back carl oh how
did i
not mention carl irvin what the [ __ ] is
wrong
carl urban is underrated thank you
catwoman uh carl urban
my god carl urban and while we're on the
topic of game of thrones
not game of thrones lord of the rings
actors david wenham as well both of them
uh underrated more underrated true
true david wenham does not have as high
as
you finish it greg i agree with you i
agree with you he is more underrated
he is a stronger performer yes yeah well
you know he's just got a higher profile
for his underrating david
david i'm narrating three i'm that
british actor with this
raspy voice which is not quite
if you give him the right wig he's he's
great
uh did we do that we did that yeah but
sam rockwell the card
thank you carlos you zoe kravitz and
carl wherever that's actually carl urban
commenting and he used a different
username because he
let's manipulate this window so i can
continue scrolling down
what are you doing i'm manipulating the
window so i can continue scrolling down
because we've actually
reached kind of the bottom of the
suitcase fine you guys have been to us
thank you
i can't do dude again can you
i'll figure it out watch watch this john
you ready i'm about to show you what
it's like to be a man
oh [ __ ] i [ __ ] it up john it's okay i
think i have an idea based on your idea
just take my hand away every time i'm
sorry turn around
turn around
oh i got a couple more people giancarlo
esposito i think is a very underrated
performer there we go
and uh i would also say elizabeth moss
who i
i'm hoping invisible man does something
for her career
um to really boost her and the science i
think more people should enroll in
scientology after that movie
um william fichner not enough people
acknowledge the guy
do you guys know william fichner is he's
an incredible actor
did you solve it john uh ish i solved it
a little bit so that's fine let's see
what we got
we're going down to lord
lone wolf military michael sheen from
underworld highly underrated
out of all the movies you said with
michael sheen you went with
underworld instead of like frost
nicknames
or the twilight saga uh i mean he's
great in underworld don't get me wrong
he's great
uh but yeah but he's got more respect
than that
i like your name lone wolf military that
just sounds like
a john wick like character justin sutton
thank you
thank you by the way by the way lone
wolf yeah i really appreciate that
thanks justin sutton happy to see your
name again dude yeah
michael shannon is fantastic and takes
shelter
vera farmiga fantastic and delroy
lindo good call he gives one of the uh
gives one of the all-time great
performances into five bloods i have
heard this when we
when we did our trailer react i haven't
seen the movie yet we did our trip i've
been so busy playing the last of us too
when we did our trailer reaction for uh
the five bloods
that was one of the things i pointed out
i was like i'm just so happy to tell roy
linder back because i
feel like yeah he was a he's a great
actor never really properly got his do
and then the number one thing out of all
the performances i'm hearing the most
about with defy bloods
is delroy lindo and michael shannon
come on guys i will fire them i will
fight him
[Music]
i wonder like because michael shannon
like he gets
roles he's known he's a creepy guy he's
creepy
he's always good he's always got this
squid or wide
eyes i'm fascinated because like weirdly
just when i
wave my metal detector of the soul over
you know michael shannon for this debate
i
i don't feel like he's overrated or
underrated
because like he's just i feel like he's
a presence he's known
but i don't know why i feel that way
because like i mean i guess you know
what would qualify
by maria hammond thanks for being here
and yes there's people in here who are
pointing out william vickner
yes tony mcguire is underrated but uh
who are we talking about
michael chan okay i i would say
that yeah michael shannon
i think that whoever knows his work
loves him all right
i think everyone who knows most people
who know his work really appreciate what
he does
but i think you can qualify an actor as
underrated if
you still have to be like who's that
again yeah uh
he's in this he's odd oh he has a lot i
know his audio you know
highly underrated in the night before
like i i think
that the doubt can put you as underrated
when you're like no this guy's been in a
gazillion films and he's still the actor
who you have to be like
who's michael shannon again a lot a lot
of people won't know the name michael
shannon that's fair that's fair
ooh michael pena grover is underrated
thank you
william sphincter thank you first person
sonny all right john who's next on the
list my friend we have
raj krishna
ooh here's an interactive one how would
you rate actors like
sean connery michael caine and samuel l
jackson
uh okay how would i rate them sean
connery is rated he's retired he's he's
he's rated
i would say a little overrated because
he slaps women
that's bad but did he do blackface not
yet not yet
that's his comeback he'll do another cg
animated scottish movie and he'll play a
black character
you know we'll we'll get it i love just
making fun of people who did blackface
i just love making fun of those things
uh so sean connery for me is rated i
would say
uh michael kane you know what's funny
about this category what you're talking
about i was bringing up a point
about sam jackson earlier sorry to cut
you off but i just i don't want to lose
his train of thought
i was bringing a yes will poulter is
underrated thank you mimi um
that uh how you left uh with [ __ ] um
sam jackson's one of those actors who
doesn't phone it in in the sense of like
he has that mentality of i worked really
hard to become an
actor i eventually broke in and i view
it as i have a job
and so no matter what i'm booking i'm
gonna do my best i'm gonna
show up and i'm gonna do my job and all
three of those actors have that like
i've listened to interviews on all three
of them
and all three of them have that kind of
mentality sean connery michael kane and
sam jackson
of like they don't really look down on
whatever work they're they've been cast
in they're like i got a job to do i'm
gonna show up and i'm gonna do it i'm
gonna do my best that's all that matters
so i i respect the hell out of all three
of them i'm gonna
i'm gonna rank them in terms of who's
the least
overrated and i think michael caine is
the least overrated
this is really cool sam jackson is in
the middle
and sean connery is uh is the most
overrated
hey guys or sam jackson i don't know
i think mark i think michael caine is
the least underrated because
or or is the most underrated because
he's the least
uh called upon i mean sean connery is
retired but he's not called upon to just
show up and just be
himself i think in our demo except for a
gold member i think in our demographic
in terms of like our age and younger
michael kane is the most underrated one
even to the
that's the one i would say okay okay um
but yeah
uh let's see here keeper sutherland
underrated what about
donald sutherland yeah he was great i've
seen this jeremy strong guy before he's
pretty good i'll jump
to you fix this oh yeah let's see here
we got
we got oh oh oh oh okay
we can at least fit this one zoe kravitz
is back
adam driver and black klansman is
underrated i agree
i agree that's the weird thing about
that movie but i'm i was watching black
klansmen
and i love that [ __ ] movie it's a
great movie and i was like
but the supporting white guy is the
strongest performer everyone in this
whole movie
yeah it's fair i i mean like i love john
david washington in that movie
he's great but everyone's great
everyone's the
highlight standout performance was a
[ __ ] adam
he did have the most intense he had to
be
there physically his wife is on the line
yeah so there is just something the
script has
for him that's a bit yeah this is the
most it's it's
yeah it's a weird thing to say with that
movie but he's really great in it for
sure
um and there are a lot of great
character actors in general in that
movie
um let me crunch this window back down
and who are you guys saying in the chat
while john's freaking that
scott atkins underrated hell yeah great
call man
goddamn how do i know that name where do
i know scott atkins from
i'll give you one hint okay he's sexy
oh does it do it for you boy the chat
overrated my girlfriend don't suck my
dick no more
ouch summer holder i used to get jared
padilecki confused
ryan rizzo gaming go to bed buddy yes
uh we got aaron beppler uh hey guys
carla goodgenie aaron thank you so much
uh say thank you once in a while john
aaron thank you geez i'm always the one
saying say thank you just
once on and what and and that's erin
without today
i haven't seen it thank you appreciate
it thank you so much for letting me be
here today
hi guys carla gagino and michael sheen
are underrated
i feel like millie bobby brown is a
little overrated
no one can do the millie bobby brown the
way millie bobby brown
like she sells the [ __ ] out of the pain
and the struggle
of using being 11. the the doing the the
11 powers
why can't i think of the word
telekinetic telekinesis telekinesis
powers like
whichever she does that it's like the
most intense nipple chills i ever had
even in stranger things season 3 when
she had the thing like clotting her leg
and she's pulling it out of her i'm like
god she's really still in the pain right
now but that's all i ever really think
of i already think of her being really
shy
or struggling the [ __ ] out of her powers
i i am so close to almost don't worry we
only got
eric horson what's he saying underrated
uh russell
tovey history boys being human banished
looking etc i don't know if i know this
movie i don't know russell tell us
look it up right now russell
i said russell toby okay russell
allison pill is underrated who else do i
have on my list i did not mention yeah
i've seen this guy russell tell me i've
seen that oh yeah here i got i got one
that i i think to be a rather
interesting underrated one
because she's in like let me see if you
can guess what i'm talking about okay
this actress yeah who i think is very
underrated
and i don't think i've seen anyone bring
her up in the entire time we've been
live
okay is in some of the biggest movies of
all time
and no one really registers like
holy [ __ ] she's in like
the biggest movies of all time okay do
you have any idea what i'm talking about
she's in like so many franchises too oh
my see that's the thing as i'm trying to
think of like who's definitive who
doesn't get their due
um avengers okay avatar
sigourney are we going back yes
sigourney weavers
remember sigourney weaver and [ __ ]
doctor stranger
oh zoe zoe donna man
okay what do you mean okay no one no
like
star trek avengers uh
what else did i say avatar avatar
i like zoe saldona uh
i think she's rated really
i don't know i've never been like moved
in a
really significant way like i haven't
seen something that had like such
substance that she was able to
significant part of so many of the
biggest movies ever and i feel like no
one ever credits her
i yeah i feel like she's not exactly she
is not credited
she does deserve credit yes she does
she's not discredited no she's not she's
not all right
m says she's perfectly great i take it
back she can go [ __ ]
all right jean jeter says uh she's all
right she can go screw herself
overrated wait no me uh mirna is saying
forgot about her underrated me i'm not
not underrated
but losers is an underrated fan uh but
mandy says underrated
i don't know where i stand i need i how
do i how do i how do i
want my own opinion how do i people
please
um you know just say yeah just say yes
underrated know me rapus
all right all right guys we're gonna
broken marshall green we're gonna wrap
this up in a couple minutes
let's do the last of these i love these
comments you guys you guys you guys have
been christians
so great here these are great hit the
eyeball and then we'll go down
hit the other eyeball all right and then
we scroll down and we got mimi
mimi stream lab dom hall gleeson
general hux underrated star wars
character
ruth ruth nega is a terrific actress
great call
germany all right
[ __ ] canary oh
tandy news tandy newton yes no she does
not she
she's been holding it down for a long
time i would say overrated
sure i'm just trying to trigger mimi m
for disagreeing with me
oh fragrance is kidding me me brett
gallup i don't know brett gail i'm
underrated olivia
coleman perfectly rated oh look at
olivia
no i don't know who the favorite woman
is i know olivia coleman right yeah i
first saw her in hot
fuzz like over almost a decade
i first saw hey ricky's back how'd that
email exchange go out for you in the
chat
oh my goodness yeah how are you doing
how are you doing were you hit up by a
bunch of weirdos
um so uh yeah olivia coleman the first
time i saw her was her oscar-winning
speech
brett gellman yeah brad gellman he's
he's murray
oh he's murray from stranger things and
he's in these
other guys too i forgot uh and he's on a
flea bag oh yeah yeah gotcha
this man gets so thank you mimi i
appreciate that my dear hmm
she's not triggered by my comment i know
well you gotta try it hard i mean if i
try harder i'm gonna cross a l i know me
if i try harder i'm gonna cross the line
that's gonna be chaos
i see some uh let's see here i see some
thomas jane love in the chat
oh john fix fix my life i don't think i
can any longer because the thing is
whenever
here's a little look behind the curtain
the thing is i can't drag the bottom of
this window up enough
that it'll scroll down like at a certain
point it just decides
this window just needs to be better okay
this window needs to be bigger
but see there's stuff underneath the
bottom i'm sorry we can't show that
we can't show the last couple super
chats oh that's what the w
in deontay w aka tongue punch box stands
for
oh do you want okay all right so we got
two more super super
dumb dominic is first call it a night
guys
dominic zep no no we're gonna see these
last two super chats and we're gonna go
through some more of your comments yeah
yeah
dominic zeferre uh edward
norton underrated if not mentioned
so i guess yeah must be a little
underrated we got eric in her stream
that dude
all right dominic thank you dominic
edward norton underrated if not
mentioned
i i i don't know what it was about
edward norton it's like
i thought he'd be you know what it is i
think the suit the really big films he
was in
he just didn't properly deliver yeah you
know like red dragon
oh bret ratner's red dragon the uh the
incredible hulk which is
very underrated now now it's considered
an upgraded marvel yeah yeah that's
underrated marvel
um but but even in like i think he's
fine in the movie i think the movie's
underrated but i think his performance
is just
okay i think everyone most people prefer
mark ruffalo
um but it's like yeah there's like
like fight club was uh not a big movie
when it came out became a cold hit
american history x
wasn't a huge film but definitely a
staple in cinema
i don't know what it is man miss him
miss edward norton
i just watched um i i didn't
i just watched a motherless brooklyn
that was the name of it and i mean he
gives
a really great performance and i forget
yeah yeah yeah
and i think he has like i think he plays
a character with tourette's
if i'm naming the right condition but uh
he's yeah
edward norton is a weird one because i
feel like there's something
in there that keeps him from maybe it's
just like how he i've heard he is to
work with or something like that or you
know
yeah but uh like we're gonna make sure
this movie doesn't do well because he's
hard to work with
no not that but i i feel like maybe he
would
be in a slightly different position like
like edward norton is a terrific actor
and i feel like he gets a good amount of
respect
so like i don't think he's necessarily
super underrated
but at the same time he's got primal
fear thank you
i don't know um we got one more from
deontay
thank you so much and really quick i do
want to read off kevin stuff
one last throughout these danny pooty
benchwards shelly yeah craig robinson
keith david all underrated
keith there you go dave enter calls and
danny poot like oh man
and then deontay sorry we can't show it
on screen right now we're having a
hard time with it deontay wimbish all
right but deontay
for tongue punch fartbox ben foster is
underrated
loved his portrayal of his role in alpha
dog
you know what else i love him in hostage
oh hey have you seen that i have not do
you know stars in it
in the film hostage mel gibson bruce
willie yeah bruce willis
ben foster i like him in the also 310 of
yuma ben foster great good call deonte
thank you by the way buddy
and then oh oh we got
with her six six always six six six
thank you erica tuesday
agree when it comes to voice actors
they're often underrated
tom cruise refuses to do voice acting
because his face would not be involved
love you guys hope you're having and all
right we and i
tweak it i love you too this is that
true about tom cruise refusing to do
voice acting i've never heard it but i
i would not actually be surprised
honestly yeah like i
you know he you know what tom cruise
would be great in
shark tale a video game character like
doing oh if he did
oh my god that would be [ __ ] awesome
mission impossible
nine should just be a video okay if he
would did one of those video games where
you know
if especially if he gets to run in there
you know run astonishers
sci-fi horror game tom cruise would be
perfect for that yeah and you would
actually have to press a lot of buttons
to run effect
you would need to like use both sticks
and yeah really make it exertion
and like if uh you know when you in a
lot of games now it's like you can only
uh sprint for so long because of realism
tom cruise you don't have to worry about
that
if you play as tom cruise's character
he's just hold x he just
sprints the entire time you just make
your way to the end of the video games
which of these controls doesn't run yes
and uh somebody just to piggyback off
this tyler slavin through an
underrated voice actor uh voiceover
artist mark hamill
i feel like mark hamill is the most
recognizable voice artist
though yes i feel like he he above all
voice art
and and to be fair he's also an actor
actor like physically on screen so i
feel like that's a little cheating
all right guys well thank you for all
the stream lab donations
thank you for all the super chats let's
go through the comments for just a
couple more minutes then we're going to
call it a night all right let's see
what's going on in here
get your comments in henry cavill i
think is a little overrated
honestly henry cavill you think is
overrated a little [ __ ] oh man of steel
man of steel how many times has man of
steel randomly been brought up in his
life
because i feel this position with him
constantly where it's
and and it a lot of it is to the films
that he's been
in but there's a lot where it's like
gotta get henry cavill harry kevin's so
good
ah henry cavill but i've never seen him
do anything that like truly gripped me
and was like damn this guy is great
dude what about
you know
[Music]
see what i did uh tim blake nelson we've
talked about him tim blake nelson
uh i saw another good one bill murray is
bill murray and zombieland
performance troy baker good call mike
cardin ricky
love you too thank you so much and oh
jennifer aniston
is overrated jennifer aniston sorry if
that's a trigger greg
says this says mimi uh-oh jennifer
aniston
is she was cheated on by brad pitt
we'd be kind of jennifer aniston but
somebody did say that brad pitt was
overrated so
yeah [ __ ] brad pitt for cheating on
jennifer aniston
yeah but as an author and everything
else i think he's amazing
yeah there is guys we are we are
broadcasting through a capture card so
you're gonna see a little d-lacing
you're gonna see a little bit of red and
red and blue ghosting it's like the
first time you've ever been high
yeah sure like what the [ __ ] i see the
waves
they call him fingers but you never
really see him thing michael bean oh i'm
glad we got that in here
michael bean oh guest starring koi sorry
michael bean it's a real rejects live
guest starring with coy jake i would
love to see
i have a chat with coy on monday about
helping him look through his channel
about some stuff so yeah
it's definitely going to happen at some
point glenn fletchler
all right let's read a couple more then
we're going to call it a night come on
guys give us a good one
that's a good one it was give us a good
one thought
glenn i thought the shroom's kicking it
gerard butler you know i'd say he's
underrated but he can't do a [ __ ]
american accent
the way british people feel about
whenever americans do
british accents yeah it's how i feel
strictly about gerard butler when he
does an american accent
like you're just not getting it man
please stop that just do the sean
connery please i use your ex go figure
we're about to wrap this up
oh but i love the i love the onslaught
of it little real however hell yeah
jessica alberto rated nah she's
perfectly rated everyone knows she can't
act
brian brian tyree henry i'll throw in
there i mean i'm glad to see him getting
more roles but uh there's a lot of great
act like
zazie bates like everybody on meryl
streep is overrated
she always shows up i just feel like
there was
no no it was like she got so many
nominations that just seemed like a
thing that you gotta do
for her it's a meme almost that she's
great so i feel like i guess by default
she has to be kind of overrated but at
the same time i'm like
i just she's always great when i see her
and stuff i think chris hemsworth right
now is perfectly rated
uh kevin hart i don't know how i feel
about kevin hart
it's been a minute since like he may
have been overrated back when like there
was a kevin hart movie coming out every
20 minutes but
i feel like at the moment ava green yeah
exceptionally thomas jane oh yeah i
think he's a little underrated
darth maul guy in the mini film you mean
the the mall
uh short like fan made film or do you
mean ray park
thoughts on actors like bruce willis sam
jackson nick cage
uh they're all amazing except for bruce
willis who has just let me down over the
years
liam hemsworth is not okay liam
is like please get me out of that man's
shadow
get me out of my brother's shadow please
liam hemsworth is
he he's raided he's fine
i don't know have any work i've seen a
liam hamster thrown like
dude's [ __ ] good i don't i can't
think of anything
no no and i i like see my favorite is
the third hemsworth because he doesn't
seem like he's trying to do the same
thing as the other two
at all yes whereas liam is like
[ __ ] from west world yeah jesse
plemmons yeah
good call he is underrated trying to
we're trying to focus on people who you
got who we haven't already talked about
in this chat fred armisen
mandy more underrated fair enough
documentary now is terrific
i like it a lot ah let's see here
shea wiggum yeah
[Applause]
oh kevin kevin's yeah
i would also okay josh dumel
rated i'm trying
come on who is the [ __ ] guy from
blind from blind spotting oh dude david
v diggs [ __ ] [ __ ] david david
diggs is a
quad is like a i don't know how many
numbers of a threat he is but like that
dude's music is great he's a great actor
he can write
he can she's a stage actor too like uh i
think
john bernthal is underrated he's like
right at the
cusp of being perfectly raped yeah he's
like almost
right that's
how do i get rated you guys joel
edgerton
when i said raided i thought of blooded
and i thought of
bright and then i thought of joel
edgerton all right guys well
thank you to everyone who has been here
in this live stream especially those
who've been here from beginning and i
know
a few of you guys i know i've been here
from since the beginning of the stream
so thank you
um thank you to everyone who contributed
in our stream labs
our super chat you guys have been
[ __ ] incredible these are always a
blast to do
um we'll probably see you guys next week
suggest some topics you know go to the
community page
leave some topics as i usually think of
the topic a little bit before we do a
thumbnail post
that's usually when i got a topic in
mind but hey what are you doing
some topics because we've been lucking
out on some of these lately what are you
interested in and yes gabriel byrne i
agree with you kristen yeah
yeah and florence pugh [ __ ] great guy
oh my god he's
going to stop with the great picks you
guys got to stop dude chris
it's ending i'm sorry burning pillow
it's ending it's been a couple hours
we're ready
love love love love you guys thank you
for being here technical issues at the
top
it's been amazing um and oh dion thanks
deandre
sweetie love you bud eric thank you for
appreciating so much during the stream
dude
ricky michael k williams hi everyone
this is like when you're there
at the [ __ ] party and you're like bye
i want to give everyone some credit
okay bye-bye everyone yeah yeah okay bye
oh tyrone magnus underrated yeah
kevin stuff this is a minimum grape
see you guys soon and uh one day i will
finish the last of us too
hopefully this week yeah one day soon
see